हां जी
हेलो हेलो
ओके
सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
ओके सो हे एवरीवन एम आई ऑडिबल
प्लीज लेट मी नो वंस एम आई ऑडिबल
ओके तो पहले
चलिए ठीक है आई थिंक अभी नोटिफिकेशन जानी
स्टार्ट हो जाएगी
ओके
ठीक है ठीक है
ग्रेट
ओके लेट मी सी मैं मैं मैं भी देख लेता
हूं यहां पे
ओके आई थिंक यस चलिए सो
वी आर नई
यस यस वी आर
नाउ लाइव
ओके वेलकम एवरीबॉडी आप सबका स्वागत है आज
के इस
धमाकेदार शानदार सेशन में
[हंसी]
ओके ठीक है।
चलिए
ओके। सो सबसे पहले तो आप सबका बहुत-बहुत
स्वागत है आज के इस लाइव सेशन में एंड आई
रियली अप्रिशिएट यू ऑल बीइंग हियर। सो अ
फर्स्ट ऑफ़ ऑल वेलकम एंड गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
ऑफ यू। नमस्ते टू ऑल ऑफ यू। आई होप आप सब
बहुत बढ़िया होंगे। बहुत मस्त होंगे। एकदम
चंगा होंगे। बढ़िया एकदम। हां काफी टाइम
हो गया बग बंटी की सेशंस को एंड यकीन
मानिए कि
अभी जो टॉपिक्स आने वाले हैं जो एक अप्रोच
होने वाला है वो बहुत डिफरेंट अब होगा एंड
काफी कुछ आपको जानने को सीखने को मिलेगा
थोड़ा मोर फ्रीक्वेंट टाइमिंग पे मोर
फ्रीक्वेंटली आपको चीजें मिलेंगी सो आप
उससे सीख सकते हैं। सो अभी भी काफी कम लोग
आए हैं। देखते हैं बाकी लोग कितने देर में
जॉइ करते हैं। अह
सर जस्ट टू बी एक्साइटेड और कौन से कौन से
एडवांस टॉपिक्स हैं? बहुत सारे हैं। वो
जैसे-जैसे आएंगी आपको पता चलती जाएगी।
पहले से मैं कुछ भी बता के नहीं रखता। कोई
मतलब नहीं बनता है। आप जैसे-जैसे टॉपिक्स
आए आप उनको एक्सप्लोर कीजिए। उनको गो थ्रू
कीजिए। एंड आफ्टर अ लॉन्ग टाइम यस आफ्टर अ
लॉन्ग टाइम गुड इवनिंग कल्पे। अह
गोट वन मोर P5 + P4 डुप्लीकेट।
कांग्रेचुलेशंस। बहुत-बहुत सर। आप बहुत
स्मार्ट दिख रहे हैं। थैंक यू वेरी मच।
थैंक यू फॉर द कॉम्प्लीमेंट।
आई लव यू। आई लव यू टू ब्रदर। ओके हाय हाय
हाय आईशा खैक्स। इट्स माय फर्स्ट लाइव।
ओके वेलकम टू द फर्स्ट लाइव। वेलकम टू द
फर्स्ट लाइव। वेलकम टू द फर्स्ट लाइव।
हां जी मैं इधर मोबाइल पर भी ना इसको चला
के छोड़ देता हूं ताकि एकजेक्टली आपको
अ
ओके मैं देख सकूं स्ट्रीम को
अ स्ट्रीमिंग बहुत लोड हो रहा है। हो सकता
है कुछ नेटवर्क का इशू होगा मे बी
इट माइट बी पॉसिबल
ओके
तो आज आपको पता है हम कौन से टॉपिक को
एक्सप्लोर करने वाले हैं, पढ़ने वाले हैं।
आपको पता है आप में से सबको
बताइए मुझे।
ओके।
ओके वेलकम टू द
आई थिंक नाउ इट शुड बी ओके।
अभी ये सही हो जाना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से।
अभी देखते हैं।
अभी सही है गाइस। अ नाउ द स्ट्रीम इज
कमिंग गुड अभी सही आ रही है आपको
बिल्कुल सही है ठीक है ठीक है गुड गुड गुड
चलिए काफी टाइम इसमें चला गया हमारा ओके
अभी सही है
इट्स फिक्स्ड ओके मैंने मोबाइल डेटाबेस
स्विच किया है आई होप कि थोड़ी सही हो गई
होगी
ओके लेट्स स्टार्ट टुडे सेशन एंड आप सबको
पता है ना कि आज हम क्या सीखने वाले हैं
व्हाट वी आर गोइंग थ्रू आप सबको पता कि हम
आज क्या करने वाले हैं? मुझे बता दीजिए।
एवरीबडी नोज़ व्हाट वी आर गोइंग अ गोइंग
थ्रू टुडेज़ टॉपिक क्या है आपके आज के सबको
पता है? लेट मी नो।
बताइए एसटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग। ठीक
है? अब देखो एसटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग है ना? इसको आप आज करने वाले
हैं। बहुत बढ़िया।
सो आज जो टॉपिक जो चीज हम करने वाले हैं
दैट इज बेसिकली नोन एज अ एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग। सो वी आर गोइंग टू
डील विद दिस पर्टिकुलर वनेबिलिटी अह इस
दिस पर्टिकुलर अटैक दैट इज़ नोन एज
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग। जिसको हम
एचटीडीपी डिसिंक अटैक भी बोलते हैं। इसको
हम एचटीडीटीपी डिसिंक अटैक भी बोलते हैं।
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग भी बोलते हैं। वी टेल
इट बोथ। लाइक ये दोनों ही कहलाता है।
दोनों ही चीजें हम इसको बोलते हैं। अब
यहां पे ये एग्जैक्टली क्यों इतना
इंपॉर्टेंट है? एंड क्यों ये एडवांस
कैटेगरी के वोलेबिलिटी में आता है? मैं
आपको उसके बारे में बताऊंगा। सारी चीजें
आपको बताऊंगा। एंड किस तरीके से आप इस
पर्टिकुलर एक अटैक का यूज करके सिर्फ जस्ट
सिंगल दिस अटैक यू कैन लॉन्च सेवरल
डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक्स। लिटरली यू कैन
लॉन्च सेवरल डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक्स। यह
इतनी ज्यादा ही डेंजरस वनेबिलिटी है। तो
बिफोर वी कम टू दिस पर्टिकुलर वनेबिलिटी
बिफोर वी स्टार्ट दिस वनेबिलिटी।
लेट मी डू वन थिंग।
हेलो हेलो एवरीबॉडी हेलो
सबसे पहले मैं आपको यहां पर बताना चाहता
हूं कि अ यहां पे काफी लोगों के जो है
मेरे पास मैसेज आते हैं। काफी लोगों के
रिक्वेस्ट आते हैं कि वीपीएस कौन सा यूज़
करें? काफी लोग मेरे से रिकमेंडेशन पूछते
हैं। तो मैं आपको वो वीpएस सजेस्ट कर देता
हूं जो मैं खुद यूज़ करता हूं। जी हां, आई
यूज़ दिस वीपीएस बाय Inte DC. आप इस वीपीएस
को यूज़ कर सकते हैं या कोई सा भी कर सकते
हैं। बट यह मैं आपको रिकमेंड बिल्कुल
करूंगा बिकॉज़ आई मसेल्फ बीन यूजिंग फ्रॉम
सेवरल मंथ्स। दिस वीपीएस सबसे बड़ी बात है
इस वीपीएस का डेटा सेंटर इंडिया में है।
तो आपके ऐसा डाटा जो है वो कहीं बाहर नहीं
जा रही है। आप इनके वीpएस का कोई सा भी
प्लान जो है वो चूज़ कर सकते हैं। एंड एक
चीज़ और है क्योंकि यह मेरे साथ कोलैबोरेट
कर रहे हैं। एंड इनकी सर्विस रियली बहुत
अच्छी है। दैट्स व्हाई मैं खुद ही यूज़ कर
रहा हूं। अगर ये इवन अगर सर् इनकी सर्विस
अच्छी उतनी नहीं होती इतना कुछ खास नहीं
होता तो मैं यूज़ नहीं कर रहा होता। एंड
इनकी आफ्टर सेल सर्विस काफी अच्छी है। अगर
आपको कोई इशू आता है टेक्निकल सर्विस काफी
अच्छी है। सारी चीजें मतलब ए टू जेड जो
चीजें हैं वो दैट इज ग्रेट। तो आप इनके
वीpएस में कोई सा भी वीपीएस जो भी आपको
वीपीएस मन करे जो भी आपके रिक्वायरमेंट के
अकॉर्डिंग आपको सूट करता है दैट वीपीएस यू
कैन यूज़ फ्रॉम हियर। कोई सा वीपीएस आप चूज़
कर सकते हैं। आप देख सकते हैं इसके
अलग-अलग प्लांस हैं इन वीपीएस के। अलग-अलग
प्लान्स आपको मिल जाएंगे। कोई सा भी आप
Linux या Windows के VPS प्लान पे गेट
स्टार्टेड करके एंड यहां पे आप उसको चूज़
करके ले सकते हैं। द मेन थिंग इज़ कि यहां
पे क्योंकि दे आर कोलैबोरेटिंग वि
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स। तो यहां पे आपको एक कूपन कोड
मैं अपने तरफ से दे देता हूं जो कि फर्स्ट
मंथ के लिए वैलिड होगा जिसको कि आप
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स 20 आप लगाओगे तो आपको सीधा
20% का डिस्काउंट मिल जाएगा फॉर द फर्स्ट
मंथ एंड यू विल गेट 799 जो कि आपके 1
महीने के लिए होगा। आप फर्स्ट मंथ के लिए
डिस्काउंट एप्लीकेबल होगा। 79 की जगह 799
में आपको यह मिलेगी। जहां पे आपको 4 GB का
रैम मिलता है। दो CPU कोर्स मिलते हैं। 50
GB की एसएसडी स्पेस मिल जाती है। 4
टेराबाइट का बैंडविच मिलता है जो कि काफी
होता है। मोर देन इनफ है आपके बग बाउंट
टास्क के लिए। एंड 1 टू 10 Gbps का पोर्ट
स्पीड मिलता है एंड फ्री बैकअप्स भी मिलते
हैं आपको थ्री कॉपीज़। ये सारी चीजें आपको
इस प्लान के अंदर मिल जाती है। ये बैकअप
जो होती है वो मोस्टली काफी लोग नहीं देते
हैं जनरली। बट ये काफी अच्छा चार टेराबाइट
का आपको बैंडविथ मिल रहा है। इट्स गुड एंड
मेरे लिए काफी बेस्ट है। मैं इसको पर्सनली
यूज़ करता हूं। एंड आई एम लाइकिंग इट। काफी
महीने से यूज़ कर रहा हूं। तो आप जा सकते
हैं। इनके कोई भी वीपीएस प्लान को
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। अदर प्ल्स को भी
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। कूपन कोड यूज़ कर
लीजिएगा। आपके लिए बेटर है। डिस्क्रिप्शन
में भी लिंक आपको मिल जाएगा। आप वहां से
भी जाके कर सकते हैं। चलिए अब यहां पे
सबसे पहले ये Lindin प्रोफाइल है मेरा।
आपको अगर Lindin पे हमसे जुड़ना होगा तो
आप मेरे को यहां पे आके फॉलो करके एंड
मुझसे जुड़ सकते हैं। lindin.com inn
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर। यहां पे हमारा
डिफ्रॉनिक्स का पेज है। डिफ्रॉनिक्स सर्च
करेंगे आप Lindin पे तो हमारी पेज मिल
जाएगी कंपनी की जहां पे आपको हमारी कंपनी
से रिलेटेड सारे अपडेट, सारे रिलेटेड जो
भी चीजें हैं वो सारी चीजें यहां पे मिल
जाती है। एंड आज की ये एडवांस टॉपिक जिस
कारण से है वो है कि हमारे WhatsApp चैनल
पे 10,000 फॉलोअ काउंट्स पूरे हो चुके
हैं। 10,000 डिफ्रॉनिक्सर हमारे साथ वहां
भी जुड़ चुके हैं। सो इट्स अ वेरी ग्रेट
माइलस्टोन। सो आप हमारे WhatsApp चैनल पे
हमें बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट है। फॉलो कर
सकते हैं। आप जाके WhatsApp चैनल पे
एक्सप्लोर चैनल्स पे जाके डिफ्रॉनिक सर्च
करेंगे आपको मिल जाएगा। या तो हमारे कोई
सी भी जो YouTube पे वीडियो होती है उसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जो लेटेस्ट लाइव वीडियोस
हैं उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइएगा। वहां
पे WhatsApp चैनल का लिंक भी मिल जाएगा
एंड यू कैन जस्ट सिंपली फॉलो अस ऑन देयर।
देन हमारा ये Twitter का पेज है dfonic
academy x.com dfonic accडy यहां पे आके
हमें Twitter पे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। एंड ये
हमारा Instagram पेज है जहां पे ऑलमोस्ट
50,000 फॉलोवर्स काउंट है। आप यहां पे आके
इनफेटिव रील्स वगैरह के लिए एंड फदर
अपडेट्स के लिए हमें यहां पे फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। एंड ये हमारी वेबसाइट है। सो
dfin.com यहां आके हमारी वेबसाइट को
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एकडमी पोर्टल पे
जाके हमारे डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट जो कोर्सर्सेस
हैं आप उनको एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एंड
हमारी कोर्सर्सेस जो हैं उनके थ्रू
स्किल्स गेन कर सकते हैं। सो चलिए हो गई
बहुत सारी यहां पे एडवर्टाइजमेंट्स एंड
सोशल हैंडल की प्रचार प्रसार। अब आते हैं
हमारे द मेन टॉपिक दैट इज एसटीडीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग। अब मैं आपको ये जो चीजें
बताऊंगा ये जो रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग बताऊंगा
ये जो टॉपिक बताऊंगा ये टॉपिक आपका दिमाग
हिला देगी। ठीक है? जो जिस तरीके से मैं
अभी आपको अभी बताने वाला हूं, जिस तरीके
से सारी चीजें समझाने वाला हूं। आपका
दिमाग हिल जाएगा क्योंकि ये टॉपिक
एक्चुअली बहुत ही ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग एंड
बहुत ही ज्यादा एडवांस एंड बहुत ही ज्यादा
यू कैन से कि एक
हाई सीवियरिटी हाईएस्ट सीवियरिटी
वनेबिलिटी यू कैन से क्योंकि इसकी एक छोटी
सी जो चीज है अगर किसी गलती हुई है अगर
किसी सर्वर के तरफ से या कोई अह किसी तरह
की सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हुई है तो
पूरे के पूरे सर्वर तो छोड़ो दूसरे यूज़र्स
तक को इंपैक्ट करती है। दूसरे यूज़र्स अदर
यूज़र्स इट इंपैक्ट्स अदर यूज़र्स एज़ वेल।
सो दिस इज़ द
द सीिवियरिटी ऑफ़ दिस वलेबिलिटी। बाकी
वलेबिलिटीज़ में क्या होता है? जैसे आप
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन वगैरह करते हो या
एक्सेस करते हो। ये अलग-अलग है। सीएसआरएफ
करते हो या आईडियोआर करते हो। अदर चीजें
करते हो तो आप एक पर्स एक स्पेसिफिक चीज
को ना आप चेंज करते हो। स्पेसिफिक चीज को
आप निकालते हो। आपको स्पेसिफिक चीज मिलती
है। स्पेसिफिक चीज को ऑल्टर करते हो। एंड
उस तरीके से सर्वर पे इंपैक्ट पड़ जाता
है। जनरली आईडीआर में यूजर दूसरे यूजर पे
भी इंपैक्ट पड़ता है। बट नॉट ऑन द मास
स्केल यू कैन से हां जिस पे आप अटैक करोगे
जिस तरीके से करते हो उस तरीके से आपका
इंपैक्ट दिखता है। यहां पे एचसीडीपी पे
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग अटैक में यहां पे क्या
होता है कि आप मास लेवल पे मल्टीपल यूज़र्स
के ऊपर अटैक कर सकते हो। अब ये सोचोगे कि
ऐसा ये ये कौन सा एक नया नया सिस्टम है?
ये कौन सा तरीका है भाई? ये क्या कहां से
आ गया है? तो मैं अब आपको यहां पे बताता
हूं कि ये किस तरीके से मैं यहां पे चीजें
यहां पे बात कर रहा हूं यहां पे। ठीक है?
अब मैं यहां पे क्या कर देता हूं? ऑनलाइन
वाइट बोर्ड ओपन कर लेते हैं। एंड यहां पे
मैं आपको इसको विजुअलाइज करके दिखाता हूं
कि इसको आप विजुअलाइज कर पाओगे। यू कैन सो
दैट यू मे अंडरस्टैंड बेटर। क्योंकि अगर
देखो ये ऐसी वोनेबिलिटी है। इसको अगर आपने
बहुत ज्यादा ध्यान से नहीं समझा तो आपको
समझ नहीं आएगी। और फिर आप कितना भी
इंटरनेट पे पढ़ लो। अभी-अभी चैट में किसी
ने बोला कि सर मैं पोच फिगर पे इसकी चीजें
को पढ़ रहा हूं या समझने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं। बट नहीं कर पा रहा हूं। कई लोग होते
हैं जो ऑनलाइन पढ़ने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं।
इसको पढ़ने की कोशिश करते हैं बट नहीं कर
पाते हैं। इसका रीज़न ये है कि ये थोड़ी सी
कॉम्प्लेक्स है। बट मैं आपको आज जितने इजी
वे में बताऊंगा ना उतने इजी वे में आपको
आज तक कहीं नहीं मिला होगा ना कभी मिलेगा।
एंड इसके मल्टीपल पार्ट्स होंगे। पार्ट वन
है ये। फर्स्ट पार्ट है। तो आप इसको शुरू
से देखिए एंड बिंदास देखिए। ठीक है? आपने
पहले कुछ ना देखा हो देखा हो उससे मतलब
नहीं है। बस इसको देखिए। अब देखिए यहां पे
बाकी अटैक्स में एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग में क्या होता है? अब जैसे एक
क्लाइंट होता है। ठीक है? एक क्लाइंट होता
है और एक क्या होती है? सर्वर होता है। अब
ये क्लाइंट आप हो।
वाई ओ एंड यू ये आप हो। अब आप रिक्वेस्ट
भेजते हो ना सर्वर को। ठीक है? तो सर्वर
को रिक्वेस्ट सिर्फ आप ही नहीं भेज रहे
हो। यह मान लो अगर यह सर्वर fb.com है।
दिस इज़ fb.com तो यू आर नॉट जस्ट यू आर
नॉट अलोन सेंडिंग अ रिक्वेस्ट टू fb.com
आप अकेले नहीं हो जो fb.com को रिक्वेस्ट
भेज रहा है। देयर आर मल्टीपल यूज़र्स दोज़
आर सेंडिंग द रिक्वेस्ट टू FB.com पूरे
वर्ल्ड से हजारों लाखों करोड़ों यूज़र्स
होते हैं। मैं अगर यह बोलूं कि एचटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग एक ऐसा अटैक है जिससे
आप ना सिर्फ इस सर्वर को सर्वर को इंपैक्ट
कर सकते हो बल्कि जो यूज़र्स रिक्वेस्ट भेज
रहे हैं उन सबको भी
आप मलिशियसली पोइजन कर सकते हो। उन सबको
भी आप हंट डाउन कर सकते हो।
उन सबको भी आप एक मशियस लोकेशन पे भेज
सकते हो। एक मास लेवल का अटैक ल्च कर सकते
हो। यह पावर है एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग अटैक का या एसटीटीपी डिसिंक अटैक
का। अब ये जो एक अटैक है ये जो वलेबिलिटी
है ये अभी के टाइम में भी इतने सारे वेब
एप्लीकेशन में है जिसका आप अंदाजा नहीं
लगा सकते। जितने भी वनेबिलिटीज अभी
एग्जिस्ट करती हैं वर्ल्ड में ये मोस्टली
सबसे ज्यादा
वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस में होगा। और इसका सबसे
बड़ा रीज़न है HTTP वर्जन वन का यूज़ होना।
जो कि आज भी कई ऐसे वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस, कई
ऐसे वेब सर्वर्स http का वर्जन वन यूज
करती हैं। 1.1
मतलब वन के वर्जन यूज़ वन एक्स वर्जन यूज़
करती हैं। रादर देन HTTP वर्जन टू। HTTP
वर्जन टू में इसको मिटिगेट किया गया है।
स्टिल देयर आर वेरियस पॉसिबिलिटीज़ बट HTTP
वन इज़
अ लॉट ऑफ़ लॉट ऑफ़ मोर टाइम्स वनरेबल।
कई सारी वनेबिलिटी कई जगह पर वनरेबल है।
अब जितनी भी वेबसाइट्स आप ब्राउज करते हो
ना जितनी भी वेबसाइट्स आप ब्राउज़ करते हो
जो एसटीp वन पे और बहुत सारी हजारों लाखों
वेबसाइट्स एचtपी वन पे आज भी काम करती है।
ऑपरेट करती हैं। http वन के जो रूल्स हैं
उनको अप्लाई करती हैं। एंड दैट्स द
सिनेरियो कि हम यहां पे बहुत वेबसाइट्स पे
ये वनेबिलिटी फाइंड कर सकते हैं। एंड यकीन
मानिए जब आप इस वनेबिलिटी को समझ जाएंगे
तो मैं आपको जरूर बोलूंगा कि गो एंड हंट
फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर वनेबिलिटी इन
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट वेबसाइट्स। इवन जो पॉपुलर
वेबसाइट्स हैं ना उनके भी सब डोमेनस में
या लेस पॉपुलर वेबसाइट्स में थोड़े उन सब
पे भी ट्राई करना है आपको हंट करने का। बक
क्लाउड हैकर वन एसv हैक के बहुत सारे
डोमेनस होंगे जो वनेरेबल होंगे इससे।
थोड़ा टाइम देना पड़ेगा। अब क्या हर टाइम
वनरेबल होते नहीं उसका भी एक क्राइटेरिया
है दैट वी आर गोइंग टू अंडरस्टैंड दैट वी
आर गोइंग टू सी कि कैसे क्यों तो मल्टीपल
पार्ट में ये वलेबिलिटी को कवर किया जा
सकता है एंड दैट वी विल बी कवरिंग सो डोंट
वरी अबाउट इट कि सर समझ में आएगा कि नहीं
मैं समझा के रहूंगा आपको बस ध्यान थोड़ा
यहां पे कंसंट्रेशन देना है। अब आप यह सोच
रहे हो कि मैं लाइव में आ गया हूं। बस ऐसे
ही थोड़ी देर देखता हूं निकल जाता हूं। तो
वह कंसंट्रेशन नहीं होता और रिकॉर्डिंग को
आप देखने में आपकी जान जाती है। मुझे पता
है क्योंकि रिकॉर्डिंग कई लोग नहीं देख
पाते हैं। कई लोगों को दिक्कत आती है।
उतना टाइम बैठ नहीं सकते। तो हो सकता है
वीडियो थोड़ी लंबी हो जाए बट आपको लाइव
देखना है।
हैकर वन के कुछ रीसेंट रिपोर्ट्स की अगर
मैं बात करूं तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
एचटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग हीलियम जो
प्लेटफार्म है उन पे एसटीp रिक्वेस्ट जी
स्मगलिंग जीएसए बंटी एसटीp रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग एक्रोनिस एचटीडीटीp रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग इन इटरनल Z जोमato जो कि
क्रिटिकल 9.8 सीवियरिटी के साथ यहां पे ये
लिस्ट हुई थी इस वबिलिटी को लिस्ट किया
गया था एंड यहां पे बाउंट को हिडन रखा गया
है मे बी माइट बी इट म इट मस्ट मस्ट बी
क्वाइट अ लॉट ऑफ़ बाउंट काफी बड़ी बाउंट
होगी। एंड नोट जेएस में क्रिटिकल 9.0 मतलब
आप देखेंगे ना कि जब ये वनेबिलिटी रिपोर्ट
हुई है अगर अच्छे से रिपोर्ट हुई है तो
इसकी सीवियरिटी हाई क्रिटिकल ही रही है।
मोस्टली क्रिटिकल ही रहेगी। अगर आप एक
अच्छे एंड पॉइंट पे रिपोर्ट करते हैं। ठीक
है?
अब आते हैं क्या होता है यह? देखो नाम से
तुम्हें इसको समझना है।
इसको नाम से समझना है आपको।
इसको आपको नाम से समझना है। एचटीडीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग अटैक। स्मगल का मतलब
होता है किसी चीज में छुपा के लेकर जाना।
व्हाट इज स्मगल? टू हाइड समथिंग। ठीक है?
किसी चीज में इसको हाइड कर लेना। किसी चीज
को और उसको वहां से लेकर जाना। जैसे आपने
सुना होगा ना स्मगलिंग। स्मगलिंग्स होते
हैं। राइट? तो वो स्मगलिंग्स का मतलब वही
स्मगलिंग है। यहां पे एक चीज के अंदर
दूसरी चीज को हाइड करके ले जाना। वही चीज
है यहां। हम एक एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट को
दूसरे एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर हाइड कर
रहे हैं और उसको आगे लेकर जा रहे हैं
सर्वर्स तक।
बस यही तो है पूरा एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग।
अब अब क्योंकि दो सर्वर्स होते हैं जनरली।
आज के जो वेब इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है आपको पता
है दो सर्वर्स काम करते हैं वहां पे। इफ़
यू डोंट नो लेट मी टेल यू कि देयर आर टू
सर्वर्स वर्किंग। कौन से सर्वर्स होते
हैं? पहले मैं आपको वो बता देता हूं। इफ
इट इज़ रिटेन हियर देन वी कैन सी नहीं तो
मैं वैसे भी बता दूंगा आपको।
हां। दो सर्वर्स होते हैं। एक होते हैं
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर्स, एक होते हैं बैक एंड
सर्वर्स। फ्रंट एंड सर्वर्स जनरली जो
सीडीएंस होते हैं, प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स होते
हैं उनको कहा जाता है और बैक एंड सर्व जो
ओरिजिन सर्वर्स होते हैं जैसे Apacचे हो
गया, नोट JS हो गया आपका या कोई भी
फ्रेमवर्क हो गया जो एक्चुअल सर्वर्स होते
हैं वो होते हैं। तो बेसिकली अगर मैं वाइट
बोर्ड पे आपको दिखाऊं तो कुछ इस तरीके का
ये दिखता है जो फ्रंट और बैक एंड सर्वर
होता है। इसको समझना बहुत जरूरी है गाइस।
अगर आप इसको नहीं समझेंगे तो आपको कुछ
नहीं समझ में आएगा। लिटरली मैं बता रहा
हूं। तो इसको समझिएगा आप। ठीक है? कि क्या
होता है फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्वर्स।
अब देखिए
सी
जो क्लाइंट होता है ना आज के वेब
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में क्या होती है? ये एक
सर्वर होती एक तो ये सर्वर हो गई। जैसे कि
यह मान लो
Google की सर्वर है। इसके पहले एक और
सर्वर्स होते हैं। एक और सर्वर होते हैं।
एंड दिस इज़ कॉल्ड दिस माइट बी अ प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर। दिस माइट बी अ लोड बैलेंसर। दिस
माइट बी अ सीडीए। ये होती है। तो
रिक्वेस्ट जो आती है वो प्रॉक्सी सर्वर के
थ्रू या सीडीएंस के थ्रू या लोड बैलेंससेस
के थ्रू होके एंड तब एक्चुअल सर्वर के पास
जाती है। सो इसको हम बोलते हैं फ्रंट
सर्वर।
इसको हम बोलते हैं फ्रंट सर्वर एंड इसको
हम बोलते हैं
बैक एंड सर्वर। दिस इज कॉल्ड बैक एंड
सर्वर।
सो यहां पे एक चैट में मेरे पास एक मैसेज
आया है शिवराज जी का। सर जी पहले एचटीडीपी
का बेसिक करवा दीजिए। शिवराज जी अगर आपने
चैनल पर थोड़ा भी कंसिस्टेंसी दिखाई होती
या अगर आप सीरियसली देख रहे होते वीडियोस
को थोड़ी भी थोड़ी भी सिंसियरली देख रहे
होते जो कि मुझे लग रहा है आप नहीं देखते
होंगे तो आपको पता होना चाहिए कि चैनल पे
एचटीटीपी का बेसिक ऑलरेडी कवर्ड है एक
पूरी क्लास ली है एचटीडीटीp की बग बंटी
में ही तो आप जाके देखिए पहले वीडियो को
उसको देखिए अच्छे से उसकी ऐसे जरूरत नहीं
है आज के सेशन के लिए उसको जरूरत भी नहीं
है आपको करने की क्योंकि आज जो भी
एससीडीपी की बेसिक्स की कवर करनी होगी वो
मैं खुद आपको करके यहां पे दूंगा। तो अगर
आप ध्यान नहीं देंगे यही तो बात है। देखो
यही दिक्कत है। आज के टाइम में दिक्कत यही
है। सबसे बड़ी दिक्कत है। पता है सब कुछ
पड़ा है चैनल पे। एक-एक वनेबिलिटी कवर्ड
है। एक-एक कांसेप्ट कवर्ड है। लेकिन लोग
देखना ही नहीं चाहते। क्यों? क्योंकि फ्री
का पड़ा है क्योंकि फ्री का पड़ा है। सच
में फ्री का पड़ा है। कल को अगर मैं यही
वीडियोस जो अभी YouTube का YouTube कोर्स
एक ल्च एक पता है ना YouTube ने फीचर ल्च
कर दिया है जिसको जिसको नाम दिया है
YouTube कोर्स के YouTube कोर्स का नाम
दिया है। मैं आपको मैं आपको
मैं आपको अगर दिखाऊं
यह देखो YouTube ने उसका नाम दिया है
YouTube कोर्स और इसमें आप कोर्स की तरह
आप अलग-अलग प्लेलिस्ट को डाल सकते हैं और
इसको पेड भी बना सकते हैं। अगर मैं यही बग
बंटी की प्लेलिस्ट जो मेरी प्लेलिस्ट है
बग बंटी की इनको मैं एज अ कोर्स डाल दूं
और इसको पेड कर दूं। पता है क्या होगा?
काफी लोग फिर सीरियस लेने लगे उस चीज को।
काफी लोग इसको बहुत ज्यादा सिंसियरली लेने
लगेंगे। बट मैं ऐसा करने वाला नहीं हूं
क्योंकि मैंने उस मोटिव से स्टार्ट नहीं
किया था इस सीरीज को। जब बग बाउंड्री की
सीरीज स्टार्ट करी थी तो वो मोटिव नहीं था
कि इसको मैं पेड करूंगा आपके लिए। तो
फिलहाल ऐसी कोई भी माइंडसेट मेरी नहीं है।
बट लोग फिर सीरियस लेंगे पक्का। श्योरली।
तो ये चीज़ जो है ना
ये चीज़ थोड़ा समझिए आप लोग।
कि पहले ही बता दी है लेकिन आज के लिए
उसकी जरूरत आपको नहीं है। तो यह जो
सर्वर्स होते हैं दो सर्वर्स होते हैं। एक
पहला फ्रंट सर्वर होता है। दूसरा होता है
बैक एंड सर्वर। इसको हम फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
बोलते हैं। दूसरे हम बैक एंड सर्वर बोलते
हैं। फ्रंट एंड सर्वर्स में जनरली जो
सीडीियंस होते हैं, प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स होते
हैं, लोड बैलेंसर्स होते हैं उनको रखा
जाता है। ठीक है? एंड बैक एंड सर्वर्स में
जो होते हैं वो आपके एक्चुअल सर्वर्स होते
हैं। दैट्स इट। तो एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग जो अटैक है बेसिकली इस अटैक में
जब एक रिक्वेस्ट को दूसरे रिक्वेस्ट के
अंदर हाइड करके स्मगल किया जाता है। दैट्स
द मेन थिंग। इस पूरे अटैक का मतलब यही है
और इसी को हम एचटीडीपी डीसिंक अटैक बोलते
हैं। डीसिंक इसलिए बोला जाता है कि जब एक
चीज को हाइड की जाती है दूसरे जगह पे ले
जाने के लिए तो दोनों सर्वर्स के बीच में
ना सिंक्रोनाइजेशन होना चाहिए। दोनों
सर्वर को सेम सेम लगना चाहिए। मतलब क्या
है? जैसे आप किसी मॉल में जा रहे हो। इसको
एक एग्जांपल के तौर पर समझिए। आपको समझ
में आ जाएगा। एक मॉल में जा रहे हो। अब
मॉल में आपने गेट पे सिक्योरिटी चेकिंग के
टाइम में आपने एक बैग रखा हुआ है। ठीक है?
उस बैग में आपने एक कोई चीज नॉर्मल सा
क्लॉथिंग का आइटम रखा है और उसके नीचे कुछ
ऐसी चीज हाइड कर दी जो बैंक अंदर ले जाना
अलाउड नहीं है। मान लो दैट इज नॉट अलाउड।
आपने ऊपर ऊपर का दिखाया। उन्होंने भी ऐसे
ही देखा और आगे जाने दिया आपको।
अब अगर अंदर जाके भी आपका वो चीज नहीं
दिखता है जो इललीगल आइटम है तब तो आप मॉल
में एंटर कर गए तब तो कोई भी दिक्कत नहीं
है। सब कुछ सब कुछ ओके है। दैट इज मतलब
आपका सिंक हो रहा है। जो सिक्योरिटी गेट
है वहां भी सब कुछ ओके है। अंदर भी सब कुछ
ओके है। सिंक हो गया तो सब फाइन है। बट
जैसे ही सिक्योरिटी गेट पे आपका सब ओके है
और अंदर जाके अंदर कोई एक सिक्योरिटी
चेकिंग हो रही है और वहां पे आपको एक कोई
लीगल आइटम आपके बैग से निकल जाता है तो
सिक्योरिटी चेकिंग वाली जो गेट है मेन गेट
और अंदर वाली गेट जो चेकिंग हो रही है वो
दोनों में डिसिंक हो जाएगा सिंक्रोनाइजेशन
हट जाएगी दैट विल बिकम डिसिंक इस केस में
एक वलेबिलिटी अराइज़ होगी जिसको नाम जिसको
बोलते हैं एचटीटीपी डिसिंक अटैक या एचटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग अटैक क्योंकि आप
इंटेंशनली कोई चीज हाइड करके करके एक जगह
से दूसरी जगह लेकर जा रहे थे। बस दैट्स
इट। तो एचटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग अटैक
में यही होता है। पूरा कांसेप्ट इसी पे
बेस्ड है कि एक रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर में
दूसरे रिक्वेस्ट को छिपा के सर्वर तक ले
जाया जाता है। एंड जिस रिक्वेस्ट को छिपा
के लेकर जाया जाता है वो एक मशियस
रिक्वेस्ट होती है। वो एक स्मगल्ड
रिक्वेस्ट होती है। इसको हम यहां पे इस
केस में स्मगल्ड रिक्वेस्ट बोलेंगे। नॉट
मलिशियस रिक्वेस्ट। तो मलेशियासी होती है
वो एक स्मग्ड रिक्वेस्ट होती है जो छिप के
जाती है एक जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर
में हो गया एसटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग यही
होता है दैट्स द एसटीपी अ
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
अभी आपको समझ में आया क्या मुझे बताइए
कितना ईजी था ना कितना ईजी था ना
एचटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग को समझना
समझ में आया आपको इतना चीज इतनी चीजें
आपको समझ में आई पहले मुझे बताइए फिर मैं
आगे बढ़ता हूं
क्योंकि अभी तो बहुत कुछ आना बचा है यार।
अभी तो स्टार्ट है। अभी तो पता नहीं
क्या-क्या आएगा। यू गॉट एवरीबॉडी गॉट
गॉट प्रैक्टिकल भी इजी होगा यार।
प्रैक्टिकल भी ईजी होगा। क्यों टेंशन
क्यों लेते हो? प्रैक्टिकल भी ईजी होता
है। देखो प्रैक्टिकल जब कोई चीज़ परफॉर्म
करते हो ना रियल एप्लीकेशन पे तो
कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी इसलिए आ जाती है क्योंकि
एक रियल सर्वर एक रियल होता है। रियल
वेबसाइट होती है। रियल सर्वर्स होते हैं।
रियल बैक एंड एंड फ्रंट एंड सर्वर्स होते
हैं। तो जरूरी नहीं है ना कि आप जब अटैक
कर रहे हो तो वो वनरेबल ही होंगे। अब हर
सर्वर अगर वनरेबल होने लगे तो फिर तो अलग
ही बात हो जाएगी।
राइट? तो यहां तक आप सब समझ गए। सिंपली
समझ गए। देखो मैंने जितना
मैंने जितना इजीली आपको समझाया है अभी वो
इतना इजी है नहीं इतना याद रखिएगा आप बट
मैंने बोला था ना कि आपको जो चीजें नहीं
समझ में भी आएंगी वो भी समझाएंगे तो
बेफिक्र रहिए अब हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं
लेट्स मूव अहेड अब आते हैं कोर कांसेप्ट
पेज वन ठीक है अभी तो देखते जाना हो सके
तो नोट बना लेना हो सके तो नोट करना नोट्स
बनाना
इट विल बी बेनिफिशियल फॉर यू। ठीक है? अब
देखो सिंस http 1.1
ठीक है? सिंस http 1.1 http 1.1 से ठीक
है? क्योंकि http 1.1 इज़ द अह अह एचटीटीp
वर्जन दैट मोस्ट वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस आर
यूजिंग। देयर इज़ देयर हैज़ बीन वाइड
स्प्रेड सपोर्ट सपोर्ट फॉर सेंडिंग
मल्टीपल एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट्स ओवर अ सिंगल
अंडरलाइन टीसीपी और एसएसएल टीएलएस सॉकेट।
तो एचटीटीपी वन का एक रूल है। एक
रूल क्या है? वर्किंग का एक तरीका क्या
है? कि यह अलऊ करता है कि एक साथ मल्टीपल
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट एक सिंगल टीसीपी
स्ट्रीम के अंदर फॉलो कर सकते हैं। फ्लो
कर सकते हैं। मतलब कि एक Google सर्वर के
पास रिक्वेस्ट जानी है। तो मल्टीपल
अलग-अलग यूज़र्स के रिक्वेस्ट जो है Google
सर्वर के साथ के पास एक TCP सॉकेट के थ्रू
जा सकती है। एक सॉकेट मतलब एक टनल के थ्रू
एक टनल है ये। एक टनल है। टनल के थ्रू एक
जा रही है। एक टनल है। समझ लो कि एक
रास्ता है। एक टनल है। उसके थ्रू बहुत
सारे रिक्वेस्ट जाके वो टनल कहां पहुंचती
है? सर्वर तक पहुंचती है। तो वहां तक जा
सकते हैं।
द प्रोटोकॉल इज़ एक्सट्रीमली सिंपल। यह
प्रोटोकॉल बहुत सिंपल है। कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है। एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट आर सिंपली प्लेस्ड
बैक टू बैक एंड द सर्वर पार्स हेडर्स
टू वर्कआउट वेयर ईच वन एंड्स एंड द
नेक्स्ट वन स्टार्ट। तो एचटीडीपी
रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो एक के पीछे एक प्लेस्ड
होते हैं। एंड जो सर्वर होता है उस
रिक्वेस्ट को पास करता है। ब्रेकडाउन करता
है वन बाय वन। कैसे? किस-किस रूल के
अकॉर्डिंग
किस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के अकॉर्डिंग एचटीटीपी
हेडर्स के रूल के अकॉर्डिंग एचटीटीपी
हेडर्स के रूल के अकॉर्डिंग। अब एचटीटीपी
हेडर्स के अंदर बहुत सारे हेडर्स होते
हैं। मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है।
जैसे कि एक आपका
अ
गेट रिक्वेस्ट पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट होते हैं
जो मेथड्स एचटीटीपी मेथड्स कहलाते हैं।
कंटेंट लेंथ होता है। ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
होती है। एक्स फॉरवर्डेड फॉर हो गई। ठीक
है? ये सारे अलग-अलग तरह के हेडर्स होते
हैं। रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स होते हैं। जब
क्लाइंट के तरफ से रिक्वेस्ट आ जाती है,
रिस्पांस हेडर होते हैं। जब सर्वर की तरफ
से रिस्पांस आती है। तो सर्वर जो है
हेडर्स को ब्रेकडाउन करके और उसके
अकॉर्डिंग उसके जो रूल है उसके अकॉर्डिंग
क्या करता है वो देखता है कि हर एक
रिक्वेस्ट
कहां पे खत्म हो रही है।
और कहां पे नेक्स्ट जो रिक्वेस्ट है वो
स्टार्ट हो रही है। दैट्स इट। एक
रिक्वेस्ट कहां पे खत्म हो रही है और और
फिर दूसरी रिक्वेस्ट कहां से शुरू हो रही
है? यही काम है सर्वर का। एचटीटीपी के
थ्रू ये काम होता है हेडर्स के थ्रू। बाय
इटसेल्फ इट इज़ हार्मलेस। अपने आप पे ये
बिल्कुल हार्मलेस है। इसको कोई इसमें कोई
हार्म नहीं है। बिल्कुल परफेक्ट है। कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है कि भैया हां, ठीक है। एक
टनल में बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट जा रही हैं।
सर्वर्स तक जानी है। सर्वर्स उसको क्या
करते हैं? अ हेडर्स के एसटीडीटीपी हेडर्स
को पास करती हैं और देखती हैं कि भैया कौन
सा रिक्वेस्ट कहां पे खत्म होना है। मतलब
कहां पे उसको टर्मिनेट कर दिया जाए। हो
गया सब रिक्वेस्ट आ चुकी है। अब उसको
फुलफिल किया जाए। कौन सी रिक्वेस्ट को अब
स्टार्ट कहां से हुई है? किस जगह से
स्टार्ट हुई है। दैट्स इट।
हाउएवर मॉडर्न वेबसाइट्स आर कंपोज्ड
ऑफ चेस ऑफ सिस्टम्स।
ऑल टॉकिंग ओवर एसटीp। मॉडर्न जो वेबसाइट्स
हैं उनमें सिस्टम्स का चैन होता है।
बहुत ही मतलब एक चेन ऑफ़ सिस्टम्स होता है।
सब एक दूसरे से बात करते हैं एसटीp के
ऊपर। दिस मल्टीटायर्ड आर्किटेक्चर टेक्स
एसटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट फ्रॉम मल्टीपल
डिफरेंट यूज़र्स एंड राउट्स देम ओवर अ
सिंगल टीसीपी टीएलएस कनेक्शन। तो ठीक है।
वही काम कि एक एचटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट जो
होते हैं मल्टीपल एचटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट को
लिए जाते हैं और फ्रॉम अलग-अलग
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट यूज़र्स और उसको एक टनल के
थ्रू पास किया जाता है। वही चीज़ है। राइट?
अब उसी को आप यहां पे विजुअलाइज़ भी कर
सकते हैं कि एक यूजर वन है यहां पे हमारा।
एक यूजर टू है यहां पे। इसकी ये ब्लू कलर
की रिक्वेस्ट है। ये ग्रीन कलर की
रिक्वेस्ट है। अब ये ब्लू कलर की
रिक्वेस्ट भी जा रही है यहां पे आपके
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर सर्वर्स के पास पहले। एंड
ग्रीन कलर वाली भी रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर्स के पास पहले। उसके बाद
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर क्या करता है? इसको बैक
एंड सर्वर के पास भेजता है एक-एक लाइन बाय
लाइन। एंड ये बैक एंड सर्वर के पास जाके
रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो टर्मिनेट या जो भी
होता है जैसे भी एचटीटीपी हेडर्स के
अकॉर्डिंग वो वहां पे परफॉर्म होती है।
उसकी जो भी काम होती है वो होते हैं। तो
यहां पे बैक एंड सर्वर तक पहुंच जाता है
जो कि हमारा रियल सर्वर है। ये कोर
कांसेप्ट था। ये एक सिंपल सा पहला कोर
कांसेप्ट है। ये समझ में आया आपको? एक एक
चीज मैं बताता चलूंगा।
हां सर मैं दिल्ली के पॉपुलर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग कर रहा हूं। सिक्स
मंथ्स डिप्लोमा मैंने इसमें 400 बर्बाद कर
दिए हैं। उनके ट्रेनर एक्सपीरियंस है
नहीं। कुछ आता नहीं है। बिल्कुल सही बात
है। ऐसे बहुत सारे ट्रेनर्स ट्रेनिंग
इंस्टट्यूट्स हैं जो पागल बनाते हैं 40 40
50 50000 लेके और कुछ नहीं सिखाते हैं।
इसलिए डिफ्रॉनिक्स डिफ्रॉनिक्स एंड
डिफ्रॉनिक्स सबसे अलग एंड द बेस्ट वन इज़
डिफ्रॉनिक्स।
ठीक है? यहां तक समझ में आया
एिएटर थैंक यू ब्रदर। भैया देखो तुम हो
यहां पे 50 55 से ऊपर। तुम में लाइक तुमने
ठोके नहीं और कमेंट्स जब पूछता हूं कि समझ
में आया तो ज्यादा इंटरेस्ट दिखाते नहीं
हो। तो अब बताओ मुझे कि मेरे को कैसे मजा
आएगा? मेरे को तो मजा आता है आपके लाइक्स
और आपके कमेंट्स और आपके इंटरेक्शन से तो
उतना तो बताओ। हां भैया देखा। अच्छा ठीक
है। चलिए इतना समझ में आ गया। अब हम
अब हम
थैंक्स एविएटर। थैंक्स। लव यू ब्रदर। लव
यू। लव यू। प्लीज आप लोग एक चीज को बहुत
बार रिपीट मत भेजिए। स्पैम लगता है। ठीक
है?
यस। बहुत दिनों बाद। ठीक है? अब आते हैं
नेक्स्ट पे पार्ट टू पे। दिस मींस दैट
सडनली इट्स क्रूशियल दैट द बैक एंड एग्रीज़
विद द फ्रंट एंड। अब देखो यह भी हब होना
चाहिए कि जब दो सर्वर्स की बात हो रही है।
एक हमारा जो भी सीडीए ओडीएन है बैकग्राउंड
सर्वर्स के पहले जो हैंडल करती है लोड
बैलेंसर है। अब फ्रंट एंड सर्वर का इसलिए
यूज़ में लिया जाता है ताकि मेन बैक एंड
सर्वर पे बहुत ज्यादा लोड ना पड़े।
सिक्योरिटी इंप्रूव्ड हो। सिक्योरिटी
इंप्रूव अह अह अच्छी हो। एंड कभी कोई अटैक
हो तो डायरेक्ट मेन सर्वर पे वो अटैक ना
होके फ्रंट एंड सर्वर पहले उसको हैंडल
करें। फिर आगे मेन सर्वर को देखेंगे फिर।
तो जब ऐसा सेटअप होता है तो यह बहुत जरूरी
है कि फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
जो है उससे हमारा बैक एंड सर्वर एग्री
करता हो। किस चीज के लिए? अबाउट वेयर ईच
मैसेज एंड्स। इस चीज के लिए कि एक मैसेज
कहां एंड कर रहा है? एक रिक्वेस्ट जो आई
है वह कहां एंड कर रही है? उसे कहां एंड
होना है? अदरवाइज एन अटैकर माइट बी एबल टू
सेंड एन एम्बग्यूस मैसेज। ए्बगियस का मतलब
होता है आर्बिटरी मैसेज का मतलब होता है
रैंडम कोई सा भी मैसेज जिसका कोई मतलब
नहीं है या मशियस मैसेज। अदरवाइज़ एन अटैकर
माइट बी एबल टू सेंड एन मलशियस मैसेज
व्हिच गेट्स इंटरप्रेटेड एज टू डिस्टिंक्ट
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट बाय द बैक।
तो ऐसा हो सकता है।
कि एक अटैकर अगर इन दोनों के बीच में सिंक
नहीं है। यह दोनों एक दूसरे से एग्री अगर
नहीं कर रहे हैं जो कि करना चाहिए। एक रूल
के अकॉर्डिंग इन दोनों को एक दूसरे से
एग्री करना है कि भैया अगर फ्रंट एंड बोल
रहा है कि एक रिक्वेस्ट मेरे पास आई है वो
यहां पे एंड हो जाती है तो बैक एंड को
उसको एग्री करना पड़ेगा। करना चाहिए। मतलब
अगर बैक एंड एग्री नहीं करता है तो उस केस
में दिक्कत है।
दिक्कत है। अब यहीं पे एक अटैकर क्या कर
सकता है? अटैकर क्या कर सकता है? कि एक
मलिशियस मैसेज को
ओरिजिनल रियल मैसेज के अंदर हाइड करके
स्मगल करके बैक एंड तक पहुंचा देगा रियल
सर्वर तक। और ऐसा हुआ तो वो इंपैक्ट रियल
सर्वर पे पड़ेगी। रियल सर्वर कैन गेट
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड। रियल सर्वर पे अगर कोई
अकाउंट्स बने हैं, वह अकाउंट्स हाईजैक हो
सकते हैं। ऑथेंटिकेशन वलेबिलिटीज आ सकती
है। एक्सेस आ सकता है। अकाउंट टेकओवर आ
सकती है।
स्कूल इंजेक्शन आ सकती है। सब वलेबिलिटी
इसमें आ सकती है। सब आ सकती है। बस इतना
जानो।
गॉट।
दिस गिव्स द अटैकर एबिलिटी टू प्रिटेंड
आर्बिटरी कंटेंट एट द स्टार्ट ऑफ द
नेक्स्ट लेजिटमेट यूएस रिक्वेस्ट। मतलब
इसी से अब अटैकर क्या कर सकता है? देखो
जैसे इस डायग्राम में आपको शो हो रहा होगा
कि एक जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है। अब
यहां पे एक अटैकर ने क्या किया? एक और
जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट में एक मशियस
रिक्वेस्ट जो ये ऑरेंज कलर की आपको दिख
रही है ना ये मलेशियस रिक्वेस्ट इसको हम
समझते हैं जो कि स्मगल्ड रिक्वेस्ट है। अब
इसको उसी में प्री अपेंड कर दिया। उसी में
क्या कर दिया इसने?
उसी ने उसी में इसने अपेंड कर दिया। जोड़
दिया। अब रिक्वेस्ट पहले भी ब्लू और ग्रीन
देखो पहले भी रिक्वेस्ट ब्लू और ग्रीन जा
रही थी। अब यहां पे अटैकर आके इसमें अपनी
ऑरेंज कलर की एक स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट डाल दी
है। एंड अब ये रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है तो
क्या जा रही है? ग्रीन देन बीच में आपका
ऑरेंज जो स्मग्ड है एंड देन ब्लू। अब जब
ये सर्वर तक पहुंचेगी तो ब्लू तो सर्वर तक
पहुंच ही रहा है पूरा। साथ में यहां पर यह
ग्रीन के साथ अपेंड हो जा रहा है। आपकी जो
ऑरेंज वाली मतलब यह सर्वर तक यह भी यह भी
जो मलिशस रिक्वेस्ट है वो भी पहुंच जाती
है। दिस इज़ एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग।
स्मगल किया जा रहा है। दिस इज़ बीइंग
स्मगल्ड।
यह स्मगल किया जा रहा है। रिक्वेस्ट को।
इतना समझ में आया आपको?
यस आप थोड़ा लेट हैं अगर आप अभी आए हैं तो
ओके
ये समझ में आया आपको
आई थिंक गलती से टैब क्लोज हो गया मेरा तो
मैं उसको ओपन कर लेता हूं।
इट्स क्लोज आउट बाय मिस्टेक।
ठीक है।
हां जी।
ठीक है। अभी सही है।
ओके। सो अभी समझ में आ गया आपको? क्लियर
क्लियर क्लियर समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट।
ठीक है।
चलिए
अब आते हैं। अब हम बढ़ते हैं नेक्स्ट की
तरफ। वी आर मूविंग टू आवर नेक्स्ट। याद
रखिएगा यह जो वनेबिलिटी है गाइस ये जो
आपको मैं आपको बता रहा हूं ना यह जो मैं
आपको अ सिखा रहा हूं इस वनेबिलिटी के बारे
में मैं आपको इस बात की फुल गारंटी देता
हूं। मैं अभी भी बोल रहा हूं क्लियर ओपनली
बोल रहा हूं कि इस तरीके से आपको कोई नहीं
बताएगा। कम से कम मतलब फ्री में तो नहीं
बताएगा। इस बात को आप थोड़ा समझिए। अगर आप
अभी सिंसियर नहीं है तो सिंसियर बन जाइए
क्योंकि आप अभी सिंसियर नहीं है तो आने
वाले टाइम में जरूर सिंसियर बनेंगे ही
बनेंगे। आपको बनना ही पड़ेगा। लाइफ की यही
एक अ ट्रुथ है कि आपको लाइफ सिंसियर बना
देती है टाइम के साथ-साथ। तो बहुत लोग
बहुत मैच्योर्ड होते हैं। पहले ही सिंसियर
हो जाते हैं। समझ जाते हैं चीजों को कि
उनके लिए क्या इंपॉर्टेंट है। बहुत लोग
अभी इग्नोर मारेंगे। सोचेंगे चलो इधर से
ये कर लिया वो कर लिया और बाद में फिर
दिक्कत होती है उनको। तो
जो चीजें आपको यहां पे मिल रही हैं। अभी
इसका जो मल्टीपल अभी इसका जब नेक्स्ट
पार्ट आएगा और भी चीजें आएंगी तो आपको वो
चीज कहीं नहीं मिलेगी।
अब आते हैं नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पे। अब देखिए
लेट्स इमेजिन दैट द फ्रंट एंड
प्रायोरिटाइज द फर्स्ट
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर
एंड द बैक एंड प्रायोरिटाइज द सेकंड
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर। फ्रॉम द बैक एंड
पर्सेक्टिव द टीसीपी स्ट्रीम माइट लुक
लाइक दिस। यह कुछ इस तरीके का दिखेगा।
इसके पहले मैं आपको यहां पर कंटेंट लेंथ
एंड ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग दो चीजों के बारे
में बताना चाहता हूं। ठीक है? पहले हम
उसको समझते हैं। फिर हम उस पे आते हैं। अब
आते हैं दो इंपॉर्टेंट
टॉपिक पे जो एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
का बैकबोन है। एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग जो होता है इनमें इन दो जो
हेडर्स हैं इनका बहुत बड़ा रोल है। और
इन्हीं पे सारा गेम है। सारा गेम इन पे
है। पहला जो है टॉपिक वो है द फर्स्ट
टॉपिक इज
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग। द पहला जो हेडर है
आपका ट्रांस इसको हम बोलते हैं
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग।
और दूसरा है कंटेंट लेंथ। ये दो हेडर्स
होते हैं। ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग एंड कंटेंट
लेंथ। दोनों को समझते हैं पहले। ठीक है?
मोस्ट एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग अराइज़
बिकॉज़ द एचटीटीपी वन वर्जन वन
स्पेसिफिकेशन माने रूल्स प्रोवाइड्स टू
डिफरेंट वेज टू स्पेसिफाई वेयर अ
रिक्वेस्ट एंड्स। कहां पे एक रिक्वेस्ट
एंड होगी और कहां से दूसरी स्टार्ट होगी।
ठीक है? कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड द ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर। दो तरीके से होती है जो
आजकल मॉडर्न एचटीपी वन जो है आपकी उसके
रूल के अंदर। ठीक है? ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
क्या होता है? इट स्पेसिफाई एनी इनकोडिंग
दैट वास परफॉर्म्ड ऑन द मैसेज बॉडी टू
फैसिलिटेट इट्स ट्रांसफर ओवर एचटीटीp।
कोई भी मैसेज मैसेज है उसको एचटीटीपी के
ऊपर ट्रांसफर कर रहे होते हैं। तो एक
इनकोडिंग जो
स्पेसिफाई की जाती है उसको हम ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग कहते हैं। ये अलग-अलग तरह के
होते हैं। जैसे जीजिप होता है, डिफ्लेट
आपका चंग्ड ये सब अलग-अलग इसके इनकोडिंग्स
होते हैं।
इट इज नॉर्मली यूज्ड टू स्पेसिफाई चंग्ड
इनकोडिंग व्हेन दिस इज एंप्लॉयड और
मोस्टली ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को चंग्ड
इनकोडिंग के लिए यूटिलाइज किया जाता है।
चंग्ड मतलब छोटे-छोटे पार्ट्स में डेटा को
भेजना। इसका मतलब ये होता है।
सो चंग्ड इनकोडिंग। छोटे-छोटे पार्ट्स में
डेटा जाएगा। छोटे-छोटे चंक्स में जाएगा
जिसको बाइट्स में मेजर किया जाता है। एंड
दूसरा हेडर होता है कंटेंट लेंथ। इट
स्पेसिफाई द लेंथ ऑफ द मैसेज बॉडी इन
बाइट्स। सॉरी यह जो ट्रांसफर कोडिंग में
होते हैं जो चंक होते हैं वह हेक्साडेसिमल
में होते हैं। आई वास रॉन्ग हियर मैंने
थोड़ा सा गलत कंटेंट लेंथ का आपको बोल
दिया बाइट्स वाला। ये हेक्साडेसिमल में
होते हैं। दीज़ आर इन द हेक्साडेसिमल। उसको
आप डेसिमल में कन्वर्ट कर देंगे उतने
बाइट्स का हो जाता है। कंटेंट लेंथ में ये
लेंथ ऑफ मैसेज बॉडी जो कि बाइट्स में होते
हैं।
उसको ये बताता है। बस दैट्स इट। अब वापस
से आ जाते हैं पीछे वाले सिनेरियो में। अब
लेट्स इमेजिन दैट द फ्रंट एंड प्रायरिटाइज
द फर्स्ट कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड द बैक एंड
प्रायोरिटाइज द सेकंड फ्रॉम द बैक एंड्स
पर्सेक्टिव द टीसीp स्ट्रीम माइट लुक लाइक
फॉलोइंग। इस तरीके का ये दिखेगा। क्या है
ये?
अब मान लो दो सर्वर्स हैं। मैंने आपको
बताया ही था। एक फ्रंट एंड एंड एक बैक
एंड। अब यहां पे इस तरह की जब रिक्वेस्ट
होगी तो फ्रंट एंड अंडर द होल्ड द फ्रंट
एंड फॉरवर्ड्स द ब्लू एंड ऑरेंज डेटा जो
फ्रंट एंड है क्योंकि वो फर्स्ट कंटेंट
लेंथ हेडर को प्रायोरिटाइज कर रहा है तो
वो क्या करेगा ब्लू एंड ऑरेंज डेटा को
भेजेगा बैक एंड को। अब ऐसा क्यों? कोई बता
सकता है? ऐसा क्यों कि फ्रंट एंड जो है
ब्लू एंड ऑरेंज डेटा ये जो ब्लू डेटा है 1
2 3 4 5 एंड ऑरेंज जो कि जी ओनली जी इसको
भेजेगा बैक एंड को। इसका क्यों? इसका रीज़न
क्या है?
ओके। वेलकम विवेक टू दिस लाइव। कई लोग तो
कई लोग लाइव छोड़ के भाग चुके हैं क्योंकि
मुझे पता है उनके बस की बात नहीं थी। इसको
समझना। आई नो क्योंकि कई लोगों को ये
कॉम्प्लेक्स लगेगा और हार मान जाते हैं कि
कॉम्प्लेक्स टॉपिक है। छोड़ देते हैं लीव
एंड वो चले जाते हैं। तो ऐसे भी उन लोगों
को उन लोगों की जरूरत भी नहीं है हमें।
हमें चाहिए जो जो हार नहीं मानते हो।
दैट्स इट। मुझे भी उनसे ही मतलब है।
लेट्स इमेजिन दैन द फ्रंटेड प्रायर द
फर्स्ट कंटेंट लेथ। अब देखो यहां पर
क्या होता क्या है मैं आपको बताता हूं।
इसका एक मेन कांसेप्ट बताता हूं। फिर उस
पे आते हैं।
इफ अ मैसेज इज़ रिसीव्ड विथ बोथ अ ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर फील्ड एंड अ कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर फील्ड। हेडर फेड अगर कोई एक ऐसी
मैसेज है चाहे वह रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज हो,
रिस्पांस मैसेज हो, कुछ भी हो व्हाटएवर
क्योंकि कंटेंट लेंथ वाली जो हेडर है और
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर है ये रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर्स में भी आते हैं, रिस्पांस हेडर्स
में भी आते हैं। क्लाइंट के साइड से भी जा
सकते हैं, सर्वर के साइड से भी आ सकते
हैं। तो जब कोई मैसेज आती है एंड उसमें
अगर हेडर में ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर एंड
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर दोनों प्रेजेंट हो जो कि
नहीं हो सकते।
ठीक है?
जो कि नहीं होने चाहिए। जनरली नहीं होने
चाहिए। कोई एक ही यूज़ होना चाहिए। बट अगर
है क्योंकि हो मतलब देखो एचटीडीपी वन के
रूल के अकॉर्डिंग टू डिफरेंट मेथड्स फॉर
स्प फॉर स्पेसिफाइंग द लेंथ ऑफ एचटीडीटीपी
मैसेज
इट इज़ पॉसिबल फॉर अ सिंगल मैसेज टू यूज़
बोथ मेथड्स एट वंस सच दैट दे कन्फ्लिक्ट
विथ ईच अदर ठीक है द स्पेसिफिक अटेम्प्ट्स
टू प्रिवेंट दिस प्रॉब्लम बाय स्टेटिंग
दैट मतलब एचटीडीटीपी वन के रूल के
अकॉर्डिंग दो मेथड एक साथ आ सकते हैं बट
अगर आते हैं तो उस केस में क्या होता है
कि अगर कोई मैसेज में दोनों ही हेडर्स हैं
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर और कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर। अब ये हेडर्स होल्डर्स कहां से आते
हैं भैया? ये कहां पे आपको दिखेंगे हेडर्स
होर्स? अगर आपको नहीं पता इफ यू डोंट नो।
तो अगर मैं कोई से भी इसमें अभी जैसे ये
मान लो वेबसाइट ओपन है। मैं यहां पे अ मोर
टूल्स पे चल के यहां पे डेवलपर टूल्स पे
चलता हूं। ठीक है? एंड यहां पे मैं अगर
नेटवर्क पे चलते हैं यहां पे। ठीक है? मैं
इसको रीलोड कर देता हूं। लेट्स रीलोड इट।
कोई सा भी एक रिक्वेस्ट ओपन कर लेते हैं।
तो ये जब आप रिक्वेस्ट ओपन करेंगे यहां पे
मैं यहां पे आपको दिखा देता हूं। तो जो भी
रिक्वेस्ट जाती है तो उसमें एक रिक्वेस्ट
होती है और एक रिस्पांस होता है। क्योंकि
रिक्वेस्ट आप करते हो सर्वर को। सर्वर
रिस्पांस देता है। तो उसी को हम हेडर
बोलते हैं। एक रिक्वेस्ट हेडर होती है।
जैसे कि आप देख सकते हैं ये जनरल हेडर्स
हैं। यहां पे ये रिस्पांस हेडर्स हैं जो
आपको यहां पे और ये आपको रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स
हैं। ये आपको यहां पे दिख रही है। ठीक है?
तो ये रिस्पांस है जो सर्वर की तरफ से आ
रहा है जिसमें कि आप देख सकते हैं कंटेंट
इनकोडिंग कैश कंट्रोल ये सारी चीजें आ रही
है और यहां पे आपको यहां पे आपको दिखेगा
लास्ट मॉडिफाइड कंटेंट टाइप क्रॉस ओरिजिन
एक्स फ्रेम ऑप्शंस ये सारे आ रहे हैं और
ये है रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स जहां पे अलग-अलग
यूजर एजेंट या रेफर ये सारी चीजें आपको
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स में आ रही है। तो ये जो
हेडर्स होते हैं मैं इन्हीं हेडर्स की बात
यहां पे फिलहाल इस केस में कर रहा हूं जो
यहां पे आपको दिख रहा है। ठीक है? चलिए।
अब तो अगर किसी पर्टिकुलर मैसेज में
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर और कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर दोनों ही प्रेजेंट है तो कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर को इग्नोर कर देना चाहिए। और
प्रायोरिटी किसको मिलना चाहिए? ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर को।
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर को जो है वो
प्रायोरिटी मिलनी चाहिए देन द कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर। बस ये सब कांसेप्ट्स हैं। ये सब आप
समझिएगा क्योंकि अगर आपने ये नहीं समझा तो
आपका बहुत सारा जो चीज है वो गायब हो
जाएगा इसके इस पर्टिकुलर वनेबिलिटी के
अंदर में। ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है।
दिस इज़ वेरी वेरीेंट।
तो यह अब आपको कांसेप्ट समझ के रखना है कि
अगर एक मैसेज में दोनों आ रहे हैं
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर और कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर तो आपको ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग जो है
उसको प्रायोरिटाइज करना है। एसडीपी वन के
रूल के अकॉर्डिंग कंटेंट लेंथ वाले हेडर
को इग्नोर कर देना है। अब ये कैसे आरएफसी
जो 2616 है उसके अकॉर्डिंग है ये। अब मैं
आपको आरएफसी 2616 पे भी लेकर अ चलता हूं।
ये है आरएफसी 2616। बेसिकली आरएफसी एक तरह
का यू कैन से कि
ईजी लैंग्वेज में पेपर होता है जहां पर
जितने भी टेक्नोलॉजी जो भी चीजें आप पढ़ते
हैं लिखते हैं जो भी चीजें आप जानते हैं
जो किस तरीके से काम करता है इन एक्चुअल
ओरिजिनली वो कैसे काम करना चाहिए उसके
बारे में पूरी डिटेल होती है आरएफसी में
एंड यही एक्चुअल रियल नॉलेज है
बाकी Google वगल और जो भी चीजें पे आपको
लिखी होती है लोगों का लिखा होता है लोगों
का चीजें होती है अपनी-अपनी चीजें भी होती
है यहां जो लिखा है यह यूनिवर्सल ट्रुथ
तो आरएफसी के 2616 आरएफसी में मैसेज लेंथ
के ऊपर जब हम आते हैं 4.4 सेक्शन में तो
यहां पर नीचे में यहीं पे लिखा हुआ है इफ
अ मैसेज इज़ रिसीव्ड विथ अ बोथ ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर एंड कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर द
लेटर मस्ट बी इग्नर्ड। यानी कि कंटेंट
लेंथ को हमें इग्नोर कर देना है। दैट्स
इट। कंटेंट लेंथ को हमें इग्नोर कर देना
है। अगर ये दोनों चीज़ हो जाती है तो।
दैट्स इट। चलिए अब आपको यहां पे क्लियर हो
गया होगा। यू मस्ट हैव क्लियर्ड इट। यह
क्लियर हो गया होगा। अब हम आते हैं यहां
पे पीछे की तरफ।
यहां पे इस वाले चीज में जहां मैंने आपसे
क्वेश्चन पूछा था कि जब इस तरह का
रिक्वेस्ट होगा और जो
हमारा फ्रंट एंड सर्वर होगा और जो बैक एंड
सर्वर होगा। अब देखो सर्वर जो होते हैं
जो मेन आपका ओरिजिन सर्वर होता है जो कि
बैक एंड सर्वर होता है जैसे Facebook,
Google ये मोस्टली एचटीटीपी के रूल को
फॉलो करते हैं। तो एचटीटीपी के रूल के
अकॉर्डिंग काम करेंगे। बट जो फ्रंट एंड
सर्वर्स होते हैं ना जैसे आपका सीडीएंस हो
गए सीडीएंस आपके जो होते हैं जैसे क्लाउड
फ्लेयर वगैरह हो गया है एडब्ल्यूएस का
जैसे लोड बैलेंसर्स हो गए हैं प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर्स जो होते हैं वो हो गए हैं ये
जरूरी नहीं है कि एचटीपी के उन रूल्स को
स्ट्रिक्टली फॉलो करें। ये लेनियंट हो
सकते हैं। थोड़े टेढ़े-मेढ़े हो सकते हैं।
अरे ठीक है कर देंगे यार। ऐसा हो सकता है
अरे करेंगे रूल को फॉलो अपनी मर्जी है
नहीं भी कर सकते हैं फ्रंट एंड सर्वर के
साथ ऐसा ही है फ्रंट एंड सर्वर्स क्योंकि
बनाए जाते हैं किनहीं के द्वारा किन्हीं
के द्वारा रूल अप्लाई किया जाता है किसी
पर्सन किसी ग्रुप ऑफ पीपल के द्वारा तो
उसको जैसे कॉन्फ़िगरेशन होगी उसके
अकॉर्डिंग वो काम करता है। बैक एंड सर्वर
के साथ भी उसके कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के साथ ऐसा हो
सकता है। बट बैक एंड सर्वर मोस्टली जो है
थोड़ा स्ट्रिक्ट बिहेव करते हैं। एंड
अकॉर्डिंग टू एचटीटीपी रूल ही मोस्टली काम
करते हैं। कभी-कभी नहीं भी काम कर सकते
हैं। तो मेरा कहने का मतलब यह है कि फ्रंट
एंड सर्वर हो या बैक एंड सर्वर हो। फिक्स
जो चीजें हैं कि किस तरीके से वो ऑपरेट
करेंगी वो उनके कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के ऊपर डिपेंड
करता है कि किस तरीके से कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड है।
दैट्स इट।
तो कई बार
जो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर है वो कंटेंट लेंथ को
प्रायरिटाइज कर देती है एंड बैक एंड सर्वर
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को जो कि जेनेरिक है कई
बार होता है। कई बार फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को प्रायोरिटाइज कर
देती है और बैक एंड सर्वर कंटेंट लेंथ को
ऐसा भी होता है। बट मोस्ट ऑफ़ द केसेस में
जो बैक एंड सर्वर है, वह ट्राई चाहती है
कि ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग ही
मैं मोस्टली जो है अप्लाई करता रहूं।
कंटेंट लेंथ को मैं थोड़ा कम वैल्यू दूं।
ये सर्वर्स मेन सर्वर्स का ओरिजिन सर्वर
का जो है वो वर्किंग है। मेन इस तरीके से
काम करता है। चलिए अब आते हैं इस
रिक्वेस्ट पे। ये रिक्वेस्ट आप यह जो आप
मैसेज है इसको देखिए। इसमें यहां पर लिखा
है फ्रंट एंड प्रायोरिटाइज द फर्स्ट
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर। फर्स्ट कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर है हमारा सिक्स। इसका वैल्यू है जो
फर्स्ट कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर है उसका वैल्यू
है सिक्स। एंड सेकंड कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर
उसका वैल्यू है फाइव। यानी कि सिक्स बाइट
डेटा फाइव बाइट डेटा। तो अब फ्रंट एंड जब
उसको फॉरवर्ड करेगा इस डेटा को तो पहले
कंटेंट लेंथ को फ्रंट एंड प्रायरिटाइज कर
रहा है और सेकंड को बैक एंड कर रहा है। तो
अगर फ्रंट एंड डाटा को फ़ॉरवर्ड करेगा आगे
भेजेगा बैक एंड को तो कितने बाइट का डाटा
भेजेगा मुझे बताइए क्योंकि फ्रंट एंड जो
है आपका वो कंटेंट लेंथ फर्स्ट को
प्रायोरिटाइज कर रहा है और उसी के
अकॉर्डिंग डेटा भेजेगा सर्वर को पीछे वाले
सर्वर को बैक एंड जो मेन सर्वर है तो
कितने बाइट का डेटा भेजेगा बताइए मुझे
यहां से देख के बताइए जो आपका इस पूरे चीज
को पढ़िए ध्यान से पढ़िए इसीलिए मैंने
बोला है कि ध्यान आपको देना पड़ेगा पूरा
घुसना पड़ेगा सेशन में ऐसे टॉपिक्स को
समझने के लिए बिल्कुल सही बोला। जिन लोगों
ने बोला 6 बाइट दे आर एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट।
क्योंकि फर्स्ट कंटेंट लेंथ को
प्रायरिटाइज कर रहा है फ्रंट एंड हमारा तो
सिक्स बाइट डेटा भेजेगा। अब 6 बाइट डेटा
कहां तक है? बताइए इसमें सिक्स बाइट डेटा
क्या है? बताइए मुझे। आप ही से चलिए पूछते
हैं ताकि आपका भी थोड़ा क्लियर होता
रहेगा। 6 बाइट डाटा क्या है यहां पे? मुझे
टाइप करके बताइए। व्हाट इज द 6 बाइट डाटा?
वन टू जी बिल्कुल सही द 1 2 3 4 5 एंड
सिक्स तो 1 2 3 4 5 एंड जी ये वन टू जी तक
का डेटा सिक्स बाइट का डेटा है। वही
भेजेगा। यही तो यहां लिखा हुआ है कि अंडर
द हुड द फ्रंट एंड फॉरवर्ड्स द ब्लू एंड
ऑरेंज डेटा यानी 1 2 3 4 5 mg
ऑन एंड
सेंड टू बैक एंड व्हिच ओनली रीड्स द ब्लू
कंटेंट बिफोर इशुइंग अ रिस्पांस।
अब जब यह पूरा डाटा भेजेगा ना 1 2 3 4 5 6
यानी 1 2 3 5 4 1 2 3 4 5 g तो यह बैक एंड
को तो पूरा भेज रहा है। बट बैक एंड सिर्फ
1 2 3 4 5 को ही पढ़ेगा। जी को नहीं
पढ़ेगा। ऐसा क्यों?
बताइए।
ऐसा क्यों?
बैकेंट जी को नहीं पड़ेगा। व्हाई दिस? लेट
मी नो।
व्हाई इज दिस? प्लीज लेट मी नो। बैक एंड
विल नॉट रीड द जी।
करेक्ट। क्योंकि बैक एंड सेकंड कंटेंट
लेंथ को प्रायरिटाइज कर रहा है। एंड सेकंड
कंटेंट लेंथ की वैल्यू क्या है? 5 बाइट।
सेकंड कंटेंट लेंथ की जो वैल्यू है वो
क्या है?
5 बाइट
समझ में आ गया? तो पांच डेटा पांच बाइट के
डेटा को वो पढ़ेगा और छठे को इग्नोर मार
देगा।
तो इग्नोर मार देगा
तो ऐसे कैसे इग्नोर मार देगा?
कैसे मार देगा इग्नोर? क्या करेगा? फिर उस
डाटा का क्या होगा? तो देखिए ब्लू व्हिच
ओनली रीड्स
ब्लू कंटेंट बिफोर इशूइंग अ रिस्पांस। दिस
लीव्स द बैक एंड सॉकेट पोइजन विद द ऑरेंज
डाटा। अब ये बैक एंड का एक सॉकेट एक टनल
होगा ना
उसमें वो जी रह जाएगा फंस के। उसी में रह
जाएगा वो। अब वो फंसा रह गया। व्हेन द
लेजिटमेट ग्रीन रिक्वेस्ट अराइव्स। अब जब
नेक्स्ट एक रिक्वेस्ट आएगी लेजिटमेट ग्रीन
रिक्वेस्ट। ये जो पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट आ रही
है पोस्ट एसtp 1.1 होस्ट example.com और
आगे कोई भी मैसेज बॉडी हो सकती है या कोई
रिक्वेस्ट हो सकती है। हो सकता है कि कोई
बंदा अपने अकाउंट में लॉग इन कर रहा हो
स्लश अकाउंट स्लैश लॉगिन कर रहा हो। ये
अकाउंट ये वाला पूरा एक यूआरएल जा रहा है।
व्हेन द लेजिटमेट ग्रीन रिक्वेस्ट अराइव्स
इट एंड्स अपेंडेड ऑन टू द ऑरेंज कंटेंट
कॉजिंग एन अनएक्सेक्टेड रिस्पांस। अब यह
क्या करेगा कि यह अपेंड हो जाएगा
जी के साथ यानी जी अपेंड हो जाएगा
पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट में
और वो पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट पता है कैसे दिखेगी
कुछ इस तरीके से जी पोस्ट एसटीp अब सर्वर
को तो पता है पोस्ट एक रिक्वेस्ट होती है
पोस्ट एक एसटीपी मेथड होती है अब अगर
सर्वर को जी पोस्ट मिलेगी जी पोस्ट उसको
मिलेगा तो वह कंफ्यूज हो जाएगा
उसको लगेगा भाई यह जी पोस्ट क्या है यार?
पोस्ट सुना था, गेट सुना था, हेड सुना था।
व्हाट इज जी पोस्ट? तो सर्वर विल गेट
कंफ्यूज्ड।
सर्वर का दिमाग हिल जाएगा। इन दिस
एग्जांपल, द इंजेक्टेड जी विल करप्ट द
ग्रीन यूज़र्स रिक्वेस्ट। अब यह जो करप्टेड
जी है, यह पूरे रिक्वेस्ट को करप्ट कर
देगा। एंड दे विल प्रोबेब्ली गेट अ
रिस्पांस अलोंग द लाइंस ऑफ़ अननोन मेथड जी
पोस्ट। और सर्वर क्या बोलेगा कि भैया ये
मेथड जो है जी पोस्ट अननोन है। हम नहीं
जानते इसको। हमने कभी पढ़ा ही नहीं है जी
पोस्ट मेथड। हम खुद नहीं पढ़ा। आपने कहां
से दे दिया? तो इसका मतलब है कि यहां पे
सक्सेसफुल हुआ वो स्मगलिंग।
यहां पर एसटीडीपी स्मगलिंग सक्सेसफुल हुई
है क्योंकि सर्वर ने एक रिस्पांस दिया है।
बोला है जी पोस्ट जैसा कोई मेथड नहीं है।
इसका मतलब है कि आपका वो जो जी जो स्मगल्ड
जी है वो पहुंच चुका था सर्वर के पास आपके
ये सब गेम के कारण।
एंड दैट रिक्वेस्ट बिकम स्मगल्ड
रिक्वेस्ट।
एंड उस स्मगल्ड रिक्वेस्ट का रिस्पांस
अटपटा रिस्पांस आया और वह आएगा अननोन मेथड
जी पोस्ट। सर्वर अटपटा आपको रिप्लाई देगा।
अब इसी अटपटे रिप्लाई के जगह अननोन मेथड
जी पोस्ट की जगह ऐसा भी हो सकता है कि कोई
यूजर अपने अकाउंट में लॉगिन कर रहा हो।
अकाउंट की इंफॉर्मेशन आ जाए सर्वर की तरफ
से और वो अकाउंट की इनफेशन अटैकर को मिल
जाए ना कि ओरिजिनल को तो मिल ही रहा है
जिसको मिल रहा है। अटैकर को भी वो मिल
जाए। अटैकर के सर्वर पे वह चला जाए। तो इस
तरीके से अकाउंट टेकओवर होता है। यह भी
मैं समझाऊंगा लेटर ऑन अभी आज ही। उसका भी
मैंने सब आपके लिए पूरा कंप्लीट डिटेल में
वह करा है।
तो ये होती है रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग।
करेक्ट। नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट जो भी नेक्स्ट जो
रिक्वेस्ट होगी ना रियल ऑथेंटिक रिक्वेस्ट
उस पे वो अपेंड हो जाएगी।
उस पे वो अपेंड हो जाएगी। अब यहां आपके
दिमाग में एक क्वेश्चन आ रहा होगा। एक
सवाल आ रहा होगा। राइट?
एक सवाल आ रहा होगा।
क्या सवाल आ रहा होगा? आप समझ रहे होंगे।
आपके मन में एक सवाल यह आना चाहिए। अगर
नहीं आ रहा होगा तो कि अगर मैं रिक्वेस्ट
भेज रहा हूं किसी सर्वर को अगर मैं
रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहा हूं सर्वर को और अगर वो
जी मेरा स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट वहां पे पड़ा है
तो मैं तुरंत रिक्वेस्ट एक और भेजूंगा तभी
तो मेरे रिक्वेस्ट के साथ वो अपेंड होगा।
नहीं तो सर्वर को तो और भी रिक्वेस्ट आ
रहे हैं एक ही टनल के अंदर में तो दूसरे
रिक्वेस्ट के साथ भी तो अपेंड हो के और
बिना मतलब का मतलब मेरे काम का तो रहेगा
नहीं। तो बिल्कुल सही बात है।
तो कई बार ऐसा होता है कि एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग के लिए आपको मल्टीपल
ट्राई करने पड़ते हैं और एक ऐसी वेबसाइट
जिस पे बहुत ज्यादा ट्रैफिक है अगर उस पे
एचटीटी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग आप करेंगे तो
मोस्ट प्रोबेबबली वो सक्सेसफुल नहीं होता
है क्योंकि एक सेकंड में उसके पास बहुत
सारे अदर रिक्वेस्ट भी आ रहे हैं। तो हो
सकता है आपके मन की रिस्पांस आपको ना
मिले। तो जो लेस क्राउडेड वेबसाइट्स हैं
या कभी ऐसी एक ऐसे टाइम पर जहां पर उस
वेबसाइट पर ज्यादा एक्टिव यूज़र्स नहीं है,
ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट नहीं जा रही है। अगर उस
टाइम पे आप करते हैं तो हो सकता है मोस्ट
प्रोबेबबली कि उस टाइम में ये अटैक ज्यादा
सक्सेसफुल आपके लिए हो जाए। जैसे अगर
इंडिया में आप किसी इंडियन वेबसाइट पे कर
रहे हैं तो रात के टाइम में 1 2 3:00 बजे
करें तो उस समय बहुत कम यूज़र्स हो सकता है
उस पे एक्टिव हो। अमेरिकन वेबसाइट पे कर
रहे हैं तो टाइमिंग देख लें। वहां के
अकॉर्डिंग अगर आप वहां के रात के
अकॉर्डिंग कर रहे हैं तो वो ज्यादा हो
सकता है आपके लिए वैल्यूुएबल हो।
दैट्स द थिंग।
ये आपको समझ में आ गया? क्लियर है भाई?
इतना ईजीली समझाने की कोशिश की है। क्लियर
है? बताओ।
बताइए।
इज एवरीथिंग क्लियर गाइस?
क्लियर मतलब इजी वे में क्लियर हो रहा है
ना? इतना इजी बताता है क्या? बताइए अब
क्या बताऊं मैं?
अरे रिक्वेस्ट में जी नहीं जा रहा। जी तो
ऑलरेडी सर्वर के पास स्मगल्ड वे में पड़ा
हुआ है ना। जी को तो सर्वर ने इग्नोर कर
दिया था ना पहले वाले रिक्वेस्ट में। ड्यू
टू दिस पर्टिकुलर मिस मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
यहां पे। तो जी तो सर्वर के पास पड़ा हुआ
है। अब जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट आई तो जेन्युइन
रिक्वेस्ट में वह अपेंड हो गया।
दैट्स इट।
नहीं बफरिंग अभी तो नहीं हो रही होगी आपको
क्योंकि अभी बिल्कुल सही चल रही है आई
थिंक एंड कनेक्शन इज़ गुड। सो ऐसी कोई खास
बफरिंग मुझे नहीं लगता आपको हो रही होगी।
इट शुड नॉट बी लाइक दैट। राइट? बफरिंग
मुझे नहीं लगता क्योंकि यहां पे क्लियर है
सब कुछ। यहां पे सही है। एवरीथिंग इज़ गुड।
हां हो सकता है आपके साइड आपके साइड इशू आ
रहा होगा।
ठीक है? तो यहां पर आपको यह चीज समझ में आ
गई कि अगर क्या यहां पे एक्सैक्टली क्या
हो रहा है? अब हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं।
ठीक है? नेक्स्ट मूव अहेड।
ये आपको समझ में आ गया था। ये मैंने बताया
था कि एचटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
वालेबिलिटी तभी आती है
बिकॉज़
दो मेन हेडर्स कंटेंट लेंथ एंड ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर्स के डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के कारण।
डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स के कारण। ठीक है?
अब आगे बढ़ते हैं। अब यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर को पहले समझते हैं। लेट्स अंडरस्टैंड
द कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर। एंड इससे रिलेटेड जो
भी चीज़ हैं, इसको समझते हैं।
ठीक है?
द कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर इज स्ट्रेट फॉरवर्ड।
यह एक स्ट्रेट फॉरवर्ड हेडर है। इट
स्पेसिफाई द लेंथ ऑफ द मैसेज बॉडी इन
बाइट्स। तो जैसे ये एक ये आपका एक
हेडर है। एक मैसेज एक हेडर है ये। इसमें
आप देख सकते हैं ये पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट है।
एक यहां पे आपको जा रही है होस्ट नॉर्मल
वेबसाइट.com कंटेंट टाइप एंड कंटेंट लेंथ
= 11 है। तो कंटेंट लेंथ 11 का मतलब है
यहां पर कि यह कंटेंट का लेंथ जैसे q
फर्स्ट बाइट यह 11 का मतलब है 11 बाइट।
ठीक है? 11 का मतलब है 11 बाइट ऑफ़ डेटा।
तो q1
= 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 ये टोटल 11 है।
ये टोटल 11 बाय डेटा है। तो बिल्कुल सही
है। सो हियर इज़ द लेंथ ऑफ़ द मैसेज बॉडी इज़
टोटल 11 फॉर q = स्मगलिंग। तो ऐसा नहीं है
कि q इक्वल टू है तो सिर्फ स्मगलिंग वग को
आप काउंट करोगे। नहीं q इक्वल टू स्मगलिंग
सब काउंट होगा बाइट्स में। तो यह है
कंटेंट लेंथ। अब हम आगे आते हैं ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग क्या होता है? तो अब देखिए द
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर कैन बी यूज्ड टू
स्पेसिफाई दैट द मैसेज बॉडी यूजज़ चंग्ड
इनकोडिंग। मोस्टली यहां पे हम चंग्ड
इनकोडिंग की बात करेंगे। जब हम एचटीडीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग की बात करते हैं।
हालांकि ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग और अलग-अलग
तरीके होते हैं। बट एचटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग के केस में हम चंक्ड ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग की बात करते हैं। छोटे-छोटे डे
चंक्स में डेटा को भेजने का जो तरीका होता
है। दिस मींस दैट द मैसेज बॉडी कंटेन वन
और मोर चंक्स ऑफ़ डेटा। चंक्स इनकोडिंग का
मतलब है अगर अगर कोई हेडर में ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग चंक्ड है। इसका मतलब है कि इस
मैसेज में डाटा तो है बट वह चंग्ड में है।
छोटे-छोटे
साइज में है। ईच चंक कंसिस्ट ऑफ द चंक
साइज इन बाइट्स। हर चंक जो है बाइट्स में
चंक साइज कंटेन करता है। एक्सप्रेस इन
हेक्साडेसिमल। और वो जो चंक की साइज होती
है हेक्साडेसिमल में लिखी होती है। नॉर्मल
1 2 3 4 बाइट नहीं लिखी होती है। जैसे
कंटेंट लेंथ में सिंपल नंबर होता है ये।
11 मतलब 11 बाइट। 10 मतलब 10 बाइट। 500
मतलब 500 बाइट्स। राइट? बट ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग में दिस इज़ बीन
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग के अंदर में ये क्या
होते हैं? कैसे एक्सप्रेस्ड होते हैं?
हेक्साडेसिमल में।
फॉललोड बाय अ न्यू लाइन फॉललोड बाय द चंक
कंटेंट।
दैट्स इट।
ये होती है। मेन ये चीज होती है। सो तीन
चीजें होती है। पहला क्या होता है? चंक
साइज इन बाइट्स एक्सप्रेस इन हेक्साडेसिमल
फॉललोड बाय ए न्यू लाइन फॉललोड बाय द चंक
कंटेन। तो इसमें हेक्साडेसिमल पहला जो यह
कंट ये है बी। ये बी है चंक साइज। आप सोच
रहे होंगे बी साइज कैसे हो गया? तो b = 11
होता है। b इज़ अ हेक्साडेसिमल नोटेशन।
डेसिमल वैल्यू इसकी 11 होती है। अगर आपको
नहीं पता तो आप सिंपली यहां पे Google पे
हेक्सा डेेसिमल टू डेसिमल सर्च कर
लीजिएगा। कोई भी कन्व्टर ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
एंड यहां पे हेक्साडेसिमल जो भी नंबर आपको
देखना है कि उसका डेसिमल कितना है। इसकी फ़
इसकी फ़ूला होती है। अगर आप फ़ूला अगर आपको
पता है तो आप फार्मूला से डायरेक्ट निकाल
सकते हैं। अदरवाइज़ आप ऑनलाइन कन्व्टर को
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। यहां पे मैं B को यूज़ कर
रहा हूं। B हेक्साडेसिमल में क्या होता
है? तो मैं कन्वर्ट पे क्लिक करूंगा तो ये
डेसिमल वैल्यू इसकी 11 आती है। सो इट्स
सिंपली 11। तो सेम चीज़ यहां पे आपको
मिलेगी।
यहां पे इसकी वैल्यू है 11। अब 11 मतलब Q
= स्मगलिंग। ये पूरा 11 है। क्यों? कैन
क्यों? क्योंकि ये एक साइज हो गई। फॉललोड
बाय द न्यू लाइन। ये न्यू लाइन आया। एंड
फॉललोड बाय द चंक कंटेंट्स। जो चंख कंटेंट
है वो।
तो ये चंक कंटेंट है। क्या है? q =
स्मगलिंग। ये हमारा क्या है? कंटेंट है।
ये जो है हमारा q = स्मगलिंग। दिस इज़ द
कंटेंट। दिस इज़ कंटेंट। यह भी साइज है जो
कि हेक्साडेसिमल में है। जब आप इसको
डेसिमल में कन्वर्ट करेंगे तो इट विल कम
टू 11। दैट्स इट।
एंड लास्ट में नमस्ते नमस्ते। यहां है
जीरो। यह जीरो क्यों है? द मैसेज इज़
टर्मिनेटेड विद अ चंक ऑफ साइज ज़ीरो। मतलब
जब किसी मैसेज को टर्मिनेट करना होता है
तो उसको उसका साइज ज़ीरो बता के उसको
टर्मिनेट कर दिया जाता है। कंटेंट लेंथ
में ऐसा नहीं होता है। कंटेंट लेंथ में
सीधा जो 11 लेंथ है बाइट्स का 11। इसका
मतलब है कि यह बताया जा रहा है सर्वर को
कि भैया 11 लेंथ की ये डाटा है। 11थ के
बाद 11 लेंथ के बाद का मतलब है कि वो डेटा
वहां पे कंप्लीट हो जाता है। वो डेटा मुझे
कंप्लीट मैंने आपको भेज दिया है। अब उसके
बाद कुछ भी नहीं है। यहां सिंपल बट
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग में हमें ज़ीरो नंबर से
ये बताया जाता है जीरो देके कि इस डेटा को
अब यहां पे एंड करते हैं। अब इसके आगे कोई
डाटा नहीं है। जो भी चंक्स में आपको मिलनी
थी मिल चुकी है। बस।
तो अगर यहां पे ये B साइज़ 11 है 11 बाइट्स
एंड यहां पे ये 11 है तो बिल्कुल सही है।
बट अगर यहां पे ये सिर्फ स्मगलिंग होती
नाइन बाइट्स की तो सर्वर को
सर्वर को लगता कि बाकी के दो बाइट कहां
है? तो सर्वर बाकी के दो बाइट के लिए वेट
करता। अगर हम यहां पे इसको टर्मिनेट नहीं
करते।
इस कांसेप्ट को समझिएगा। कि अगर हमने
सर्वर को बताया कि भैया 11 बाइट की डाटा
है यह पूरी और उसको 11 बाइट भेज दिया तो
सर्वर खुश हुआ और फिर जीरो करके उस
रिक्वेस्ट को टर्मिनेट कर दिया। बट अगर 11
बाइट की डेटा है आपने बी में 11 बी दिया
है 11 डेसिमल और आप सर्वर को नाइन बाइट्स
ही भेज रहे हो तो सर्वर जो है एडिशनल दो
बाइट के लिए वेट करता रहेगा।
वेट करेगा, वेट करता ही रहेगा। और जो वह
वेट कर रहा है
उसी को हम टाइम डिले बोलते हैं। टाइम गैप
बोलते हैं। एंड उसी टाइम डिले टाइम गैप
एक तरीका है एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
फाइंड करने का कि इस पर्टिकुलर सर्वर में
एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट इस पर्टिकुलर एंड पॉइंट
पे रिक्वेस्ट पे एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग है या नहीं है। ये पहला तरीका
होता है टू फाइंड बाय टाइम गैप टाइम डिले।
यही टाइम डिले कांसेप्ट है जो अभी आगे
चलके जब हम प्रैक्टिकल्स वगैरह करेंगे तो
आपको ये कांसेप्ट तब समझ में आएगा। तब याद
आएगा आपको कि अरे हां यार टाइम गैप यही तो
हो रहा है यहां पे इस पर्टिकुलर सीन में।
देखा छोटी-छोटी चीजों से कैसे कांसेप्ट
निकलती है। अगर यही कांसेप्ट अब कई लोग
ऐसे हैं देखो देखो कितनी देखो दुख की बात
दुख की बात क्या है
कि
पीपल आर देयर इन साइबर सिक्योरिटी डोमेन
जो बहुत परेशान होते हैं उनको जॉब नहीं
मिलती है वो बोलते हैं जॉब नहीं है एंड
पीपल आर देयर
जिनको सीखना भी नहीं है अब सोचो हमारे साथ
लाखों लोग जुड़े हैं चैनल के थ्रू
WhatsApp के थ्रू थ्रू डिफ्रॉनिक्स ये सब
के थ्रू
लाखों लोग हैं जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी में
इंटरेस्टेड हैं। लाखों चलो लाखों जुड़े
हैं। 500 होंगे इंटरेस्टेड। अरे छोड़ो
10,000 इंटरेस्टेड होंगे। उनको भी हटाओ।
5000 होंगे नहीं 1000 होंगे इंटरेस्टेड।
अब लाखों लोग हैं जुड़े हुए। 1000 तो कम
से कम बहुत इंटरेस्टेड होंगे ना। 1000 में
से 500 लोग होंगे जो बग बंटी वीएपीटी में
इंटरेस्टेड होंगे। चलो 500 नहीं यार। 250
लोग होंगे। अरे नहीं नहीं 200 लोग होंगे
ज्यादा है 100 लोग होंगे
अरे सर 100 हो सकते हैं अरे 100 भी हटाओ
50 होंगे यार चलो 50 भी नहीं है लाइव में
बताओ 50 लोग भी इस तरह के कंटेंट को फ्री
में जो मिल रहा है आपको वो नहीं देख रहे
क्योंकि उनको लगता है दो चीजें
पहले की रिकॉर्डिंग मिल रही है जो कि वह
कभी जिंदगी में सही से नहीं देख पाते हैं
अगर हाईली मोटिवेटेड नहीं है तो और दूसरी
कि उनको लगता है फ्री का कंटेंट है
अवेलेबल है। चलो चल जाएगा काम चल जाएगा।
बट इसकी वैल्यू आपको उस दिन समझ में आएगी
आप लोगों को जब यह पूरा प्लेलिस्ट पूरी की
पूरी ये जो वीडियोस हैं
वो अचानक से कभी आपका
पेड हो जाए। तब आप हमें बोलेंगे कि अरे सर
आपने तो बिजनेस बना लिया। इसका पेड कर
दिया। एक रीजन बता दो पेड ना करने की और
एक रीजन बता दो इस प्लेलिस्ट को हटाने की
नहीं मतलब मेंबर्स ओनली ना करने की यही है
रीज़ंस करते हैं लोग काफी लोग करते हैं
क्योंकि उनको लगता है कि कोई वैल्यू नहीं
मिल रही है राइट
दिस द दिस इज़ दीज़ आर द वैल्यूज़ दिस दिस
शुड बी टेकन सीरियसली अगर आप सीरियस है इन
चीजों के लिए तो बाकी आपकी मर्जी है आप
अपने दोस्तों के बीच इनको जरूर बताइए तो
तो यह है ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग
ठीक है? सो द सर्वर एक्सपेक्ट्स 11 बाइट्स
ऑफ एक्चुअल डाटा। तो जब हम यहां पर चंक
साइज 11 बता रहे हैं तो सर्वर को चाहिए कि
11 ही डाटा आए 11 बाइट की वो एक्सपेक्ट
करेगा। ये आप समझ में आ गया आपको?
ये आपको समझ में आ गया?
एवरीवन रिप्लाई। 40 लोग हैं। देखते हैं
कितने लोग रिप्लाई करते हैं। देखते हैं कि
कितने लोग बस ऐसे ही हैं। तो बताइए मुझे
इतना तक समझ में आया?
आ गया।
ओके ग्रेट हिमांशु। थैंक यू।
[हंसी]
ओके।
ग्रेट। ठीक है? अब हम आगे बढ़ते हैं। अब
आते हैं यहां पे। यह मैंने ऑलरेडी आपको
बताया। ऑलरेडी बताया। ठीक है? कि
एचटीडीटीपी स्पेसिफिकेशन के अकॉर्डिंग रूल
के अकॉर्डिंग
जो होती है अगर दोनों ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
और कंटेंट लेंथ एक साथ आ जाए तो कंटेंट
लेंथ को इग्नोर कर देना है। इट शुड बी
इग्नोरर्ड।
ठीक है?
अब आते हैं नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पे। चलिए अब
यहां पे एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है उसको समझिए।
एक चीज याद रखिएगा
यह जो कांसेप्ट्स हैं ये कांसेप्ट्स अगर
आप नहीं समझेंगे तो एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग आप कभी भी हंट नहीं कर पाएंगे।
बक बाउंट इस पे नहीं कर पाएंगे। आप हंट ही
नहीं कर पाएंगे किसी टारगेट के ऊपर। मैं
लिख के आपको गारंटी के साथ देता हूं। अगर
आपका इसका बाकी जो वनेबिलिटीज़ है वो तो
कहीं-कहीं से आप देख के चैटिटी करके आप
करके अटैक कर लेते हो। ठीक है? नॉर्मल से
आप पेलोड मिल गया। एक कोई चीज का
प्रीडफाइंड स्क्रिप्ट मिल गई। आपने चला
दिया हो गया। दैट्स इट। ये समझोगे नहीं तो
होगा नहीं। मैं लिख के आपको इस चीज की
गारंटी देता हूं। इसको समझना जरूरी है।
इसीलिए मैं इतना इन डेप्थ आपके लिए
स्लाइड्स प्रिपेयर की है। मैंने मैं
स्लाइड जल्दी प्रिपेयर नहीं करता। मैं
बहुत ज्यादा हेक्टिक चीज लगती है। मैंने
ये पूरी स्लाइड जो है रिसोर्सेज आपके लिए
प्रिपेयर करी है। एंड तब ताकि एक प्रॉपर
वे में आपको सारी चीजें बता पाऊं।
ठीक है?
अब देखिए
दिस माइट बी सफिशिएंट टू अवॉयड ए्बिगिटी
व्हेन ओनली अ सिंगल सर्वर इज इन प्ले। अब
देखो बट नॉट व्हेन टू और मोर सर्वर्स आर
चेंज्ड टुगेदर। इन दिस सिचुएशन प्रॉब्लम्स
कैन अराइज़ फॉर टू रीज़। अब देखो ये जो
प्रॉब्लम है कि दोनों अगर आ जा रहे हैं
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग या कंटेंट लेंथ। ये
प्रॉब्लम तब नहीं आएगी जब कोई एक सिंगल
सर्वर यूज़ हो रहा हो। जैसे कि आपने Google
सर्वर को कांटेक्ट किया। सिर्फ Google
डायरेक्ट Google सर्वर को आप कांटेक्ट कर
पा रहे हो। बीच में कोई प्रॉक्सी सर्वर
नहीं है, सीडीएंस नहीं है, अ लोड
बैलेंससेसर्स नहीं है। तब तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। तब ये वलेबिलिटी आएगी ही नहीं।
अराइज़ ही नहीं होगी। याद रखिएगा। अगर कोई
आप ऐसे सर्वर को कांटेक्ट कर रहे हैं,
वलेबिलिटी फाइंड करने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं
जिससे आप डायरेक्ट कांटेक्ट कर रहे हैं।
बीच में कोई सीडीए नहीं है, कोई लोड
बैलेंसर नहीं है, कुछ भी नहीं है, तो ये
वनेबिलिटी एक्सिस्ट नहीं करेगी वहां पे।
इसका मतलब है सिंगल सर्वर्स वाले जो भी
डोमेनस हैं, वेबसाइट्स हैं जो कि मोस्टली
आज के केसेस में नहीं होते हैं। मतलब सब
हर वेबसाइट एक किसी ना किसी सीडीएन के
पीछे है, प्रॉक्सी सर्वर के पीछे है,
व्हाटएवर तो ये वनेबिलिटी नहीं है। बट जब
मल्टीपल सर्वर जैसे फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड
सर्वर का कांसेप्ट आ जाता है तब यह
प्रॉब्लम है। प्रॉब्लम क्या है? सम
सर्वर्स डू नॉट सपोर्ट द ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर्स इन रिक्वेस्ट्स। कुछ
सर्वर्स तो ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर्स ही
नहीं सपोर्ट करते।
कुछ सर्वर्स तो ट्रांसफर कोडिंग हेडर्स ही
कंटेंट लेंथ
जो है वो आपका मेन है। हेडर है। कंटेंट
लेंथ उसको प्रायोरिटाइज कर देते हैं। कई
बार कई सर्वर्स सम सर्वर्स दैट डू सपोर्ट
द ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर कैन बी
इंड्यूस्ड नॉट टू प्रोसेस इट। मैंने लास्ट
एक एक जगह पर मैंने थोड़ा सा एक वो मिक्स
मिस्टेक कर दी थी बोलने में आपको कि जो
बैक एंड सर्वर है वो ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग
ही ऑलवेज वो करता है। ऐसा कुछ नहीं है।
दैट डिपेंड्स कि किस टाइप के हेडर्स आ रहे
हैं। वो डिपेंड करता है।
तो कुछ हेडर्स कुछ सर्वर्स ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग को सपोर्ट ही नहीं करते। कुछ सर्व
जो हैं वो सपोर्ट तो करते हैं हेडर्स।
सम सर्वर् दैट डू सपोर्ट द ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग हेडर कैन बी इंड्यूस नॉट टू
प्रोसेस इट इफ द हेडर इज फस्टकेटेड इन सम
वे कुछ सर्वर जो सपोर्ट करते हैं उन उनके
उनको हम ऐसा करवा सकते हैं ना कि उनके
अंदर वो ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को हाइड किया
जाए। उनको ऑफ फस्टकेट कर दिया जाए। उनको
हिडन वे में भेजा जाए ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
को। उनको पता ही ना चले कि भैया ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग यहां पर प्रेजेंट है। ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को हाइड कर दिया जाए सर्वर से।
ऐसा
करने की कोशिश की जा सकती है।
इफ द फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्वर्स बिहेव
डिफरेंटली इन रिलेशन टू द ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर। क्योंकि ऑफस्टकेट हो चुका
है। हाइड कर चुके हैं हम। देन दे माइट
डिसए्री अबाउट द बाउंड्रीज़ बिटवीन द
सक्सेसिव रिक्वेस्ट्स लीडिंग टू
रिक्वेस्ट। स्मगलिंग वलेबिलिटी। अब अगर
फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर के रिलेशन में
डिफरेंट बिहेव करने लगे। क्योंकि क्योंकि
क्या हुआ कि ये रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है मान
लो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर के पास ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग भी गई है और कंटेंट लेंथ भी गया
है। अब फ्रंट एंड सर्वर ने क्या किया?
किसी तरीके से ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को ऑफ
फस्टेट कर दिया। हाइड कर दिया। तो अब जो
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है वो कंटेंट लेंथ जा
रही है वहां पे सर्वर के पास। अब सर्वर को
कंटेंट लेंथ पे फॉल करना पड़ेगा। कंटेंट
लेंथ को यूज़ करना पड़ेगा। तो यहां पे अगर
ये डिसए्री करती है सर्वर
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर के ऊपर जिसको कि
हाइड किया गया है फ्रंट एंड सर्वर के
द्वारा। तो ये उस
चीज से डिसएग्री कर जाएगी बाउंड्रीज़
बिटवीन सक्सेसिव रिक्वेस्ट। कि कौन सी
रिक्वेस्ट कहां पर खत्म होनी है, कौन सी
रिक्वेस्ट कहां से शुरू होनी है। एंड इसी
से एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग जो है वह
स्टार्ट होती है आपकी वलेबिलिटी।
ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। बस सिंपल सा
फंडा है। ये बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा है कि कुछ
सर्वर्स ट्रांसफर कोडिंग सपोर्ट नहीं
करते। कुछ सर्व जो है सपोर्ट करते हैं। तो
उनको उनसे हम ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को ही छुपा
लेंगे। दिखने नहीं देंगे। अब कैसे
छुपाएंगे वो भी हम देखेंगे। उस पे भी हम
आएंगे। कैसे छिपाएंगे? इसका भी मैंने रखा
हुआ है आपके लिए कि हाउ वी कैन हाइड वी
विल कम टू दैट इन द लेटर पॉइंट। अब आते
हैं डीसिंक का मतलब क्या होता है?
डीसिंक का मतलब क्या होता है? मैं बोल रहा
हूं ना आपको कि एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग को डीसिंक एचटीपी डीसिंक अटैक भी
कहा जाता है। व्हाट दिस डिसिंक एक्चुअली
मीन्स? मॉडर्न वेब स्टक्स ऑफेन चेंज
मल्टीपल एसटीपी प्रोसेसर्स जैसे किडीएन या
रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी या लोड बैलेंसर्स जो होते
हैं वहां से होके एप्लीकेशन या ओरिजिन
सर्वर तक जाते हैं रिक्वेस्ट तो मल्टीपल
जो एसटीपी रिक्वेस्ट होती हैं वो सीडीए
रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी इन सब के थ्रू हो के कहां
जाती है? ओरिजिनल सर्वर या जो बैक एंड
सर्वर है वहां तक जाती है। ईच लिंक मस्ट
अग्री वेयर वन रिक्वेस्ट एंड्स एंड द
नेक्स्ट बिगिन। तो हर वो जो लिंक है हर जो
वो चेन है तो दोनों फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड
सर्वर को एग्री करना पड़ेगा कि एक
रिक्वेस्ट कहां पे खत्म होती है और दूसरी
रिक्वेस्ट कहां से शुरू होती है ये
एग्रीमेंट होनी जरूरी है। अगर वो
एग्रीमेंट नहीं हुई तो दिक्कत है।
असदुल्लाह कैन आई जॉइन वीएपीटी कोर्स? यस
आप अगर वीएपीटी के आपके पास लिंक है आप
अभी भी आना चाहते हैं एंड जो रिमेनिंग
सेशंस हैं जो अभी रिसेंटली सेशंस तीन हुए
हैं उनको अगर रिकॉर्डिंग से आप कवर करना
चाहते हैं तो बिल्कुल यू कैन एनरोल
डेफिनेटली यू कैन एनरोल यू विल गेट द
एक्सेस आप तीन रिकॉर्डिंग से कर लीजिएगा
बाकी नेक्स्ट अपकमिंग वीकेंड से आप लाइव
सेशंस को ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा ठीक है यू कैन
अगर आपके पास पेमेंट लिंक है तो एनरोलमेंट
क्लोज है बट इफ यू हैव यू कैन डू अब देखो
डिसिंक हैपेंस व्हेन द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्वर पास द सेम टीसीपी
स्ट्रीम डिफरेंटली। मतलब एक ही टीसीपी
स्ट्रीम है। एक ही टनल से रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है। अब बैक एंड सर्वर किसी और तरीके
से उसको पास कर रहा है। उसको पढ़ रहा है।
समझ रहा है। फ्रंट सर्वर किसी और तरीके से
समझ रहा है। तो यहां पे दोनों में डिसिंक
हो जाएगा। दोनों में एग्रीमेंट खत्म हो
जाएगी। दोनों डिसएग्री कर जाएंगे। दोनों
का एग्रीमेंट नहीं होगा। और उस केस में
वहां पे होता है एचटीटीपी डिसिंक एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग। दैट्स लेट्स एन अटैकर
प्लेस एक्स्ट्रा बाइट दैट वन साइड ट्रीट्स
एज द पार्ट ऑफ द फर्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट।
अब अटैकर क्या करेगा? एक छोटा सा अपना
मलेशियस रिक्वेस्ट डाल देगा। तो एक जो
सर्वर है
ठीक है? एक जो सर्वर है उस उसको क्या
लगेगा कि ये तो नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट है जो जा
रही है। बट दूसरा जो सर्वर है वो समझेगा
कि एक नया रिक्वेस्ट है। दोनों में
डिफरेंस आ गई। पहले वाले सर्वर को लगेगा
यह तो वही रिक्वेस्ट है।
और दूसरे सर्व को लगेगा कि अरे यह तो एक
नया रिक्वेस्ट है यार। दिस इज अ न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट। जैसे जी हमारा जी हमारा
नॉर्मली चला गया था फ्रंट एंड के तरफ से
और जाके बैक एंड के पास बैठ गया था।
तो जी फ्रंट एंड के लिए नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट
थी।
है ना? उसने जी तक भेज दिया। बट बैक एंड
के लिए वो जी जो है अपेंड हो के और एक नए
रिक्वेस्ट के तौर पे जी पोस्ट हो गया था।
दैट्स द थिंग। समझ में आया? तो इस तरीके
से ये स्मगल्ड रिक्वेस्ट कहलाते हैं। वो
जो जी था रिक्वेस्ट वो स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट
था। वो स्मगल्ड
डेटा थी। फ्रंट एंड सर्वर्स में ये सब आते
हैं। इंजिंग्स हो गया। एचए प्रॉक्सी
एसीडीएं हो गई। लोड बैलेंससेस हो गए। बैक
एंड में Apache Note JS ओल्ड फ्रेमवर्क्स
ये सब होते हैं। ये जो बैक एंड सर्वर है
मोस्टली ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंक्ड को
सपोर्ट करते हैं मोस्टली। एंड जो फ्रंट
एंड सर्वर है वो मोस्टली कंटेंट लेंथ को
प्रायोरिटाइज करते हैं। मतलब प्रायोरिटाइज
मतलब ज्यादा प्रायोरिटी देते हैं। एंड
दैट्स इट।
आज के लिए पहले की देखने की जरूरत नहीं
है। आज एकदम फ्रेश कंटेंट है। अब हम यहां
पे नेक्स्ट पे आते हैं। अब ये डी सिंक का
जो एचटीडीटीp डी सिंक है उसका एक
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन है जिसको मैं समझाता हूं
आपको। बिल्कुल बिल्कुल रिक्वेस्ट कीजिए
आप। इसका ये एक डेमोंस्ट्रेशन है। क्या
है? कोर कांसेप्ट डेमोंस्ट्रेशन है कि आप
देख सकते हैं यह एक पूरी की पूरी टीसीपी
स्ट्रीम है जो यह जो होती है ना वह टीसीपी
स्ट्रीम का मतलब है जो कि पूरी टनल है ये
टनल ये पूरी की पूरी टनल है इसमें आप देख
सकते हैं कि एसटीp रिक्वेस्ट डेटा जो है
यहां पे ठीक है ये फ्रंट एंड सीज़ फ्रंट
एंड किस टाइप का डेटा देखता है तो फ्रंट
एंड पार्ट्स कंटेंट लेंथ को देखता है बैक
एंड जो है वो ट्रांस कोडिंग को देखता है
और इस तरीके से पूरी डाटा जा रही है। अब
डिसिंक अकर्स व्हेन फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड
डिसए्री ऑन द रिक्वेस्ट बाउंड्री। अब ये
रिक्वेस्ट बाउंड्री पे डिसए्री कर जाते
हैं। लीविंग अनपास्ड डेटा इन द स्ट्रीम।
अब ये रिक्वेस्ट बाउंड्री पे क्या कर रहे
हैं?
डिसए्री डिसए्रीमेंट दिखा रहे हैं। अब
इसकी रिक्वेस्ट बाउंड्री ये रही। इसकी ये
रही। दोनों की डिफरेंट है। तो यहां पे ये
दोनों एक दूसरे से एग्रीमेंट नहीं दे रहे
हैं। एंड ये डिसिंक कहलाता है। दैट्स इट।
अब आते हैं कि एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग अटैक को परफॉर्म करने की तरीके
से कि इसको परफॉर्म कैसे किया जाता है?
हाउ एंड व्हाट टाइप ऑफ एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग अटैक्स आर देयर? कितने तरह के
होते हैं? हम उस पे अब आ जाते हैं। ठीक
है? ये जानना जरूरी है। किसी का कोई
क्वेश्चन है तो आप पूछ लीजिए। तब तक इफ
एनीवन हैविंग एनी टाइप ऑफ क्वेश्चंस? सर
ये कंप्लीट बग बाउंटी कोर्स है या पहले
वाला देखना पड़ेगा? अरे भैया क्या बातें
करते हैं यार एक टॉपिक है यार क्या दिस इज
अ टॉपिक
ये इंडिपेंडेंट टॉपिक है आप देख सकते हैं
इनको टाइम आउट कर देते हैं एक ही क्वेश्चन
को बार-बार पूछ रहे हैं ये
ओके ऑल क्लियर
चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात है।
सर इस टॉपिक को आप पहले भी अ पढ़ा चुके हैं
क्या? नहीं नहीं पढ़ाया नहीं पढ़ाया।
सभी को क्लियर है? आप लोग रिप्लाई नहीं
करते हो यार। रिप्लाई अच्छा एक बात बताओ
जब आप देख रहे हो 40 लोगों से भी ज्यादा
लोग यहां पे देख रहे हैं तो रिप्लाई करने
में आपको क्या दिक्कत आती है बताइए मुझे
मतलब रिप्लाई करते हो तो आपका बैलेंस
अकाउंट बैलेंस डिडक्ट होता है
क्या होता है
ऑल क्लियर ठीक है अब हम यहां आते हैं कि
ये रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग कैसे होता है? किस
तरीके से यह होता है? ठीक है? अलग-अलग तरह
के रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग क्लासिक रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग अटैक्स इनवॉल्व प्लेसिंग बोथ द
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड द ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
हेडर इंटू अ सिंगल एचटीपी वन रिक्वेस्ट
एंड मैनपुलेटिंग दीज़ सो दैट द फ्रंट एंड
एंड बैक एंड सर्वर्स प्रोसेस द रिक्वेस्ट
डिफरेंटली। क्लासिक जो रिक्वेस्ट हैंडलिंग
अटैक है, रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग अटैक है,
एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग, इसका तरीका ही
यही है कि http वन रिक्वेस्ट जो होती है,
जो एचटीपी वर्जन वन की रिक्वेस्ट होती है,
उसके अंदर दोनों को लाया जाए कंटेंट लेंथ
को भी और ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को भी। दोनों
को लाया जाए और इन दोनों को मैनपुलेट किया
जाए ताकि फ्रंट एंड जो है वह अलग तरीके से
रिक्वेस्ट को प्रोसेस करें और बैक एंड अलग
तरीके से करें और दोनों के बीच में
एग्रीमेंट ही ना हो पाए। दोनों एक दूसरे
को डिसए्री करें। दोनों के बीच
डिसिंक्रोनाइजेशन हो जाए।
दैट्स इट। दिस एग्जैक्ट वे इज़ व्हिच इज़ डन
डिपेंड्स ऑन द बिहेवियर ऑफ़ द टू सर्वर। और
ये किस तरीके से होगा? ये दोनों सर्वर के
बिहेवियर पे डिपेंड करता है। अब दोनों
सर्वर किस तरीके से बिहेव कर रहे हैं?
इनके भी बिहेवियर को देखना पड़ता है। भाई
ये सर्वर से है तो क्या हुआ? बिहेवियर तो
देखना पड़ेगा। अब देखिए clt पहला अटैक है
cl.tt दूसरा है t.cl तीसरा है t.t अब ये
क्या है? एक-एक करके समझते हैं। ठीक है?
लेट्स अंडरस्टैंड सिंगल सिंगल। सिंगल
सिंगल पीस में इसको समझते हैं।
ओके पहला है clte
दिस इज़ कॉल्ड द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर यूसेस द
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड द बैक एंड सर्वर
यूसेस द ट्रांसफर एंड कोडिंग हेडर इसका
मतलब ये है clt मतलब पहले कंटेंट लेंथ है
बाद में ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग है तो पहले
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर होता है बाद में बैक एंड
सर्वर होता है तो पहले फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
कंटेंट लेंथ को प्रायरिटाइज कर रहा है एंड
बैक एंड सर्वर ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को
प्रायरिटाइज कर रहा है। tcl
इसका मतलब फ्रंट एंड सर्वर ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग को प्रायरिटाइज कर रहा है एंड बैक
एंड सर्वर कंटेंट लेंथ को प्रायरिटाइज कर
रहा है। एंड tt मतलब कि दोनों ही सर्वर्स
दोनों ही सर्वर फ्रंट एंड और बैक एंड
दोनों ही ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को सपोर्ट कर
रहे हैं। अगर दोनों ही सपोर्ट करने लगे और
दोनों ही ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग में हम चले
जाएं फिर तो दोनों में दिक्कत नहीं आएगी।
कोई कोई प्रॉब्लम होगी नहीं। तो उसमें हम
क्या करते हैं कि ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग एक जो
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग है यहां पे बट वन ऑफ़ द
सर्वर्स कैन बी इंड्यूस्ड मतलब या तो बैक
एंड को कर दो या फ्रंट एंड को कर दो।
दोनों में से किसी भी एक सर्वर को एक
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को हाइड करवा देना है।
तो दूसरा कंटेंट लेंथ पे ऑटोमेटिकली फॉल
हो जाएगा। दूसरा फोर्स हो जाएगा कंटेंट
लेंथ को यूज करने के लिए। यह तीन तरीके से
आपका जो है एसटीडी पेरिकल स्मगलिंग अटैक
होती है। दिस थ्री वे। आई होप यू गॉट आई
होप यू अंडरस्टुड दिस थिंग। तीनों आपको
समझ में आ गया? क्या हो रहा है तीनों के
केस में? बताइए। फटाफट बताइए यार। तीनों
के केस में समझ में आ रहा है?
गॉट इट। ओके। ठीक है आयुष? बढ़िया। अगर पता
चले आप लोगों को अच्छी बात है। वेरी गुड।
यस क्लियर
देख रहा हूं दो-तीन लोग ही रिप्लाई कर रहे
हैं।
विवेक आयुष
सर कैसे पता चलेगा कि कौन सा सर्वर क्या
यूज़ कर रहा है। पता चलेगा। पता चलेगा। अभी
अभी बताऊंगा कैसे पता चलेगा।
अभी बताऊंगा कि कौन सा सर्वर क्या यूज कर
रहा है। अभी पता चल जाएगा।
ठीक है।
अब नेक्स्ट मूव करते हैं।
नेक्स्ट की तरफ आते हैं। द फर्स्ट वन इज
clt वलेबिलिटी कंटेंट लेंथ ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग वलेबिलिटी
जिसमें
पहला स्टेप है हमारा सॉकेट को पोइजन करना।
सर्वर का जो सॉकेट है जो टनल है उसको
पोइजन करना।
कैसे करेंगे? देखिए
इस पर्टिकुलर केस में द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
यूसेस द कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर। ये तो पता बता
ही दिया था मैंने कि cl डॉटt में फ्रंट
एंड कंटेंट लेंथ को करेगा और बैक एंड
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को। द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
यूज़ द कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड द बैक एंड
सर्वर यूज़ज़ द ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर। वी
कैन परफॉर्म अ सिंपल एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग अटैक एज फॉलोज़। अब देखिए कैसे
होगा ये। इसमें भी अब कुछ कांसेप्ट है उस
पे भी हम आएंगे डील करेंगे। ये एक आपको
दिख रही है रिक्वेस्ट। अब इसमें
आप देखिए यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ 13 है
एंड ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंक्ड एंड यहां पे
ज़ीरो हो जा रहा है।
अब देखो द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर प्रोसेससेस द
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड डिटरमाइन दैट द
रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी इज़ 13 बाइट 13 बाइट्स
लॉन्ग। अप टू द एंड ऑफ स्मग्ड। स्मग्ल्ड
तक यह 13 बाइट का है। अब यह कैसे 13 बाइट
का है? आपको समझ में आ रहा है? यह 13 बाइट
कैसे है? स्मगल्ड को पहले पढ़ते हैं। 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 ये 8 बाइट का है। ये 8 बाइट
का है। तो ये 13 बाइट कैसे हो गया? मुझे
बताइए। कैन एनीवन टेल मी?
कैन एनीवन टेल मी हाउ इट गॉट टेराबाइट?
स्मगल्ड तक ये टेराबाइट कैसे है?
हां सन
r या r n यू कैन से r n यू कैन से या
सिर्फ n भी यू कैन से। अब इसमें ना एक
फार्मूला यूज़ होता है।
हां, अब इसमें एक फार्मूला यूज़ होता है।
मैं आपको बताता हूं। लेंथ को मेजर करने के
लिए। लेंथ को मेजर करने में एक फार्मूला
यूज़ होता है। न्यू लाइन
फार्मूला यूज़ होता है। ठीक है? अब मैं
आपको यहां पे ये बताता हूं किस तरीके से
होता है। थोड़ा ध्यान दीजिएगा। थोड़ा सा
ध्यान दीजिएगा। यू विल गेट टू नो।
ठीक है?
हां। सब कुछ ऐड होगा। सब कुछ ऐड होगा। मैं
आपको बताता हूं। एग्जैक्टली एग्जैक्टली
क्या होता है? है। मैं आपको बताता हूं।
ठीक है?
सो यहां पे इन अ चंग्ड मैसेज इसको आप
ध्यान से देखिएगा। इन अ चंक्ड मैसेज द
बॉडी कंसिस्ट ऑफ जीरो
और मोर चंक्स।
ईच चंक कंसिस्ट ऑफ चंक साइज। एक तो चंक की
साइज होती है। ठीक है? फॉललोड बाय अ न्यू
लाइन। अब यह जो न्यू लाइन होती है ना, यह
इसको डिनोट करते हैं R n या फॉरवर्ड स्लैश
बैक एंड जो भी आपको बोलना है इसको बोल
लीजिए। कुछ इस तरीके से ये डिनोट होती है।
RN
कुछ इस तरीके से यह डिनोट होती है
इस तरीके से और इसको
काउंट किया जाता है। दिस हैज़ बीन काउंटेड
ये काउंट होते हैं। तो जब मैं बात कर रहा
था व्हेन आई वाज़ टॉकिंग अबाउट
दिस पर्टिकुलर लेंथ जो कि 13 लेंथ की है।
वह मैं ऐसे टाइप ऐसे बात कर रहा था। आई
वास टॉकिंग कि
यह 1 2 ये देखो यहां पे
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ये हो गए।
यहां पे एक है दो 10
यहां पे एक है तो 10 जो कि आपका यहां पे
दिख रहा है जो कि स्लश r n है एंड यहां पे
एक ऑलरेडी ज़ीरो है एंड इसके बाद स्लश r n
तो तीन यहां पे 13 टोटल ये 13 लेंथ की हो
गई यानी ये ज़ीरो r n तीन यहां हो गए फिर
स्लैश r n दो यहां हो गए पांच हो गए और 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 आठ यहां हो
गए तो आठ और पांच 13 टोटल लेंथ हो गई 13
बाइट्स की अब आपको समझ में आया ये नाउ यू
गॉट
r n की पावर
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो ये समझ में आया
आपको अब
गॉट इट इसलिए यह स्मग्ड तक 13 हुआ।
अदरवाइज 13 कैसे होता?
हां, बब पे दिखती है। बिल्कुल सही बात है।
बब सूट इसको सिंपलीफाई करके आपको देता है।
बब सूट के अंदर ये डेटा चंक्ड वे में स्लश
आर स्लश एन तरीके से ही दिखती है। मतलब वो
सिंपलीफाई हो के दिखती है ताकि ईज़ली आप
उसको एडिट कर पाएं, देख पाएं। राइट? यहां
पे ये चीज़ यहां पे आपको सामने नहीं दिख
रही है। बट ये हिडन है। यहां पे स्लैश RN
दैट्स द थिंग। न्यू लाइन न्यू लाइन जो
होती है वो इसी तरीके एक आपका चंक साइज
देन आपका जो आपका rn r n इस तरीके से ये
फॉर्मेट को फॉलो करता है। तो जो फॉर्मेट
यहां पे हमने यहां पे देखा वो यही फॉर्मेट
है कि चंक साइज है आपकी। अब वो चंक साइज
कुछ भी हो सकती है। व्हाटएवर हेक्साडेसिमल
है ज़ीरो है खत्म हो गई। फॉललोड बाय ए न्यू
लाइन। न्यू लाइन होती है। फॉललोड बाय द
चंक कंटेंट्स। जो भी चंक कंटेंट्स होते
हैं वो चंक कंटेंट होता है यहां पे। तो वो
आपको यहां पे दिखती है।
दैट्स इट। तो अब यहां पे देखिए द फ्रंट
एंड सर्वर प्रोसेससेस द कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर
एंड डिटरमाइंस दैट द रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी इज़ 13
लॉन्ग।
इससे फायदा बहुत फायदा होगा। बहुत फायदा
होगा। अभी देखते जाओ यार। अभी तो देखो। 13
बाइट लॉन्ग अप टू द एंड ऑफ़ स्मगल्ड। दिस
रिक्वेस्ट इज़ फ़ॉरवर्डेड ऑन टू द बैक एंड
सर्वर। अब इसने तो कंटेंट लेंथ के
अकॉर्डिंग 13 किया। अब 13 तक ये जीरो
स्मगल सब कुछ है तो इसने आगे फॉरवर्ड कर
दिया। कि लो भाई सारा मैंने फॉरवर्ड कर
दिया क्योंकि सारा इसमें है 13। अब क्या
होता है? द बैक एंड सर्वर प्रोसेस द
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर। अब बैक एंड तो
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को देखेगा ना। अब
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग में क्या है? चंग्ड है।
और चंग्ड में क्या है? ये ज़ीरो। का मतलब
है कि खत्म। भैया अब खत्म। एंड सो ट्रीट्स
द मैसेज बॉडी एज यूजिंग चंक्ड इनकोडिंग इट
प्रोसेससेस द फर्स्ट चंक व्हिच इज स्टेटेड
टू बी ज़ीरो लेंथ। अब ये पहले चंक को
प्रोसेस कर रहा है जो कि ज़ीरो है यहां पे।
सो इट ट्रीटेड एज टर्मिनेटिंग द
रिक्वेस्ट। इसका मतलब है रिक्वेस्ट को
टर्मिनेट कर दिया जाए। जब ट्रंक जब आपका
चंक साइड ज़ीरो है, रिक्वेस्ट को टर्मिनेट
करने का मतलब होता है द फॉलोइंग बाइट्स
स्मगल्ड आर लेफ्ट अनप्रसेस्ड। अब इसके बाद
का जो बाइट है स्मगल्ड वाला यह तो
अनप्रोस्ड रह गया। इसको तो पूरा का पूरा
इसको भेज दिया हमारे फ्रंट एंड ने।
हमने फ्रंट एंड ने तो भेज दिया पूरा का
पूरा। अब जो हमारा बैक एंड है वो ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग के अकॉर्डिंग चंक के अकॉर्डिंग
काम कर रहा है। जिसको जीरो मिल चुका है।
मतलब उसको बंद रिक्वेस्ट को वहां पे क्या
करना है? टर्मिनेट करना है। तो अब ये जो
स्मगल्ड है जो ये आया था हमारे सर्वर के
पास यह तो ऐसे ही पड़ा रह गया जैसे वो जी
पड़ा रह गया था। याद आया वो जी पोस्ट वाली
जी?
याद आई जी पोस्ट वाली जी कैसे जी हमारे
वहीं पर जी रह गए थे हमारे भाई जी जो है
कैसे वहीं पर रह गए थे जी रहे थे वो सर्वर
के अंदर एक ठग लाइफ एक मशियस लाइफ जी रहे
थे
गॉट इट तो उसी तरीके से अब ये स्मगल्ड
वाली जो है चीज ये है हमारा स्मगल्ड जो
डेटा है ये जो बॉडी मैसेज है। यह हो गया
हमारा अनप्रस्ड एंड द बैक एंड सर्वर विल
ट्रीट दिस दीज़ एज़ बीइंग द स्टार्ट ऑफ़ द
नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट इन द सीक्वेंस। अब बैक
एंड सर्वर जो है उसको ट्रीट करेगा कि भैया
एक रिक्वेस्ट तो खत्म हो गई। अब एक नया
रिक्वेस्ट आने वाला है। आने दो आने दो।
जस्ट लेट इट कम। अब उसी में ये स्मगल्ड
वाला जो डाटा है उसको अपेंड कर देगा।
क्योंकि स्मगल तो ऑलरेडी उसके पास पड़ा है।
उसको लगेगा कि यह नया रिक्वेस्ट ही है। जो
आया है मेरे पास स्मगल्ड के साथ। तो अगर
किसी कोई रिक्वेस्ट आती है गेट सश अकाउंट
लॉग इन तो [हंसी] स्मग्ड गेट तो स्मगल्ड
पोस्ट अनएक्सेक्टेड रिस्पांस
ये होता है। सॉरी
अब यहां पे
इसको
थोड़ा विजुअलाइज करके समझते हैं। अच्छे से
और भी ज्यादा अच्छे से इसको विजुअलाइज
लेट्स विजुअलाइज इट।
पहला स्टेप पोइजनिंग द बैक एंड सॉकेट।
इसमें क्या था? क्या किया था हमने? यह एक
अटैकर है। यहां आपको ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ
में आ जाएगी। कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स है यहां
पे एंड ट्रांस कोडिंग चक्ड है। अब क्योंकि
ये फ्रंट एंड सर्वर है तो कंटेंट लेंथ को
प्रायर करेगा cl.tt अटैक में। तो अब इसने
क्या किया? छह लेंथ तक का 6 बाइट तक का
डेटा क्या किया? फॉरवर्ड कर दिया। अब छह
बाइट कौन से हैं? देखिए ये एक जो आपका है
ठीक है? ये 6 बाइट
डेटा को आगे भेजेगा। तो 6 बाइट कौन है? एक
ये हो गया।
2 3
ठीक है? चार
यहां पे आपको दिखेगा कि 0
rn
r n ये 6 बाइट आपके इसने यहां पे भेजा।
बस सिंपल। अब ये जा कौन सी रही है 6 बाइट?
किस तरीके से 6 बाइट जा रही है कि यह जो
जीरो है आपका यह जैसा कि मैंने बताया rn
तो ज़ीरो के बाद स्लश RN है
RN ये रहा और R ये रहा।
राइट? तो 3 2 5 1 6 G पोस्ट के पहले वाले
6 बाइट्स के डेट आ गए।
अब यहां पे क्योंकि ये 6 बाइट की लेंथ को
कंसीडर कर रहा है तो इसने 0 rn rn जो है
इसको भेज दिया। सिंपल
अब बच गया कौन डेटा? जी पोस्ट एचटीटीp
1.1n ये डेटा बच गई। तो यूसेस कंटेंट लेंथ
फॉरवर्ड रिक्वेस्ट सेंट यूसेस ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग।
यूसेस ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
सीज़ ज़ीरो चंक। अब जो बैक एंड सर्वर है वह
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को यूज़ कर रहा है। और
यहां पे उसने ज़ीरो देखा और रिक्वेस्ट को
वहां पे क्या किया कि रिक्वेस्ट को
टर्मिनेट कर दिया। अब रिमेनिंग डेटा क्या
हो गई? जी पोस्ट वाली हो गई जो उसके पास
है। TCP सॉकेट बफर में पड़ गई ये जी पोस्ट
वाली। यही तो है। फ्रंट एंड फॉरवर्ड्स
ओनली द पार्ट इट सीज़। बैक एंड प्रोसेस इट
एंड लीव्स द स्मग्ड प्रीफिक्स इन इट्स
बफर। और बैक एंड जो क्या किया? बैक एंड ने
उसको प्रोसेस किया और उसने जीरो के
अकॉर्डिंग प्रोसेस कर दिया क्योंकि यहां
पर इनकोडिंग जीरो है। चंक्ड इनकोडिंग जीरो
है तो टर्मिनेट कर दिया और इसके बाद जी
पोस्ट एचटीp 1.1 RN ये वैसे की वैसे इसके
बफर में पड़ी रह गई। इट स्टेड इनसाइड इट्स
बफर। दैट्स इट। अब दूसरे सिनेरियो में जो
स्मगल है वो कैसे हो रहा है? तो अब यहां
पर एक लेजिटमेट यूजर है जो रियल लेजिटमेट
है। यह तो अटैकर कर रहा था। यह लेजिटमेट
यूजर है। इसने एक लेजिटमेट रिक्वेस्ट भेजी
है। गेट http 1.1 ये गेट रिक्वेस्ट भेज
रहा है। कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे एंड यहां पे
क्या है? ट्रांसफर एंड कोडिंग चंग्ड। अब
फ्रंट एंड जो है कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स बाइट
देख रहा है अगेन। तो इसने क्या किया?
कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स जो है वो भेजा। कौन से
सिक्स? कंटेंट लेंस सिक्स भेजा। ये जी
पोस्ट वाली जो पहले से पड़ी एक तो ये है और
ये जो लेंथ है का ये जो आपका फ्रंट एंड है
ये कंटेंट लेंथ के अकॉर्डिंग ये भेज रहा
है जो भी कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे पड़ा है इसका
जो भी कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे होगा उसके
अकॉर्डिंग तो ये कंटेंट लेंथ में मान लो
गेट एचटीडीटीp 1 RN है यहां पे कुछ एक
कंटेंट लेंथ डिफाइंड है तो उसको फॉरवर्ड
कर देगा
एंड पहले से अब इस इस कंटेंट लेंथ में भी
वही वाली कंटेंट लेंथ है 0 RN RN जो पहले
से भेजा गया था और इसको को जब भेजेगा तो
अगेन यह जो बैक एंड सर्वर है अगेन क्या
करेगा टर्मिनेट करके और इसको गेट एचटीटीp
जो है 11 आरn ये भी बफर में चला जाएगा
टीसीp सॉकेट बफर में
तो अब क्या हो रहा है कि टीसीp सॉकेट बफर
में यहां पे जी पोस्ट भी है जो आपको पहले
वाला था और अभी गेट जो एक ऑथेंटिक
रिक्वेस्ट है वो आ चुकी है तो अब एक
ऑथेंटिक रिक्वेस्ट के साथ एक मशियस
रिक्वेस्ट को कॉनकटनेट कर दिया गया एप
अपेंड कर दिया गया, जोड़ दिया गया।
मतलब एक लेजिटमेट रिक्वेस्ट आई है यहां पे
ये जो कि इसके बफर में गई है सर्वर के
पास। और पहले से एक जीप पोस्ट वाली मलिशस
स्मगल्ड रिक्वेस्ट थी। तो द विक्टिम्स
रिक्वेस्ट इज़ कनकटनेटेड विथ द स्मगल्ड
प्रीफिक्स जो स्मग्ड प्रीफिक्स थी कॉजिंग
द बैकेंड टू प्रोसेस ए मैलफॉर्म्ड और
अनइटेंडेड रिक्वेस्ट। अब बैकेंड जो है एक
अनइटेंडेड रिक्वेस्ट भेज सकता है अटैकर
को। एट अटैकर को रिस्पांस जो है
अनइटेंडेंट रिस्पांस भेजा जा सकता है बाय
द सर्वर।
यह डायग्राम आपको क्लियर होगा। आई थिंक
क्लियर हो रहा होगा इस डायग्राम से कि
दोनों ही किस तरीके से एक जेन्युइन
रिक्वेस्ट के ऊपर में यहां पे अगर मैं
आपको दिखाऊं एक जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट के ऊपर
में किस तरीके से एक ये वाली रिक्वेस्ट जी
पोस्ट वाली एक स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट जो है वह
आके अपेंड हो चुकी है।
यहां तक समझ में आया आपको?
बताइए
इफ यू गॉट टिल हियर यहां तक आपको क्लियर
है?
यहां तक सब कुछ इजी है। इट्स नॉट टफ लाइक
दैट टफ। ठीक है? इसको थोड़ा देखिए कुछ अगर
क्लियर नहीं भी होगा ना तो आप रिवाइज़ जब
करेंगे ना इस सेशन को तो आपको ज्यादा
क्लियर हो जाएगा। अच्छे से क्लियर हो
जाएगा। अब हम आगे बढ़ते हैं t.cl वन
एबिलिटी। अब हम उल्टा आते हैं t.cl पे
ट्रांसफर एन कोडिंग कंटेंट लेंथ। अब इसमें
क्या होगा कि फ्रंट एंड ट्रांसफर एन
कोडिंग को प्रायरिटाइज करेगा और बैक एंड
कंटेंट लेंथ को प्रायोरिटाइज करेगा। ठीक
है भैया? चलिए देखते हैं। अब कुछ इस तरीके
का एक आपके पास हेडर होगा। इसमें पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट एक पोस्ट मेथड के यूज़ करके यहां
पे क्या है? ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंग्ड है।
कंटेंट लेंथ थ्री है। एंड यहां पे लिखा है
एट स्मगल्ड ज़ीरो। अब देखो क्योंकि अब यह
tcl है तो फ्रंट एंड हमेशा ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को यहां पर पहले प्रायोरिटाइज
करेगा। तो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर प्रोसेस द
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर। अब ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर जो है चंग्ड है। ये आपको
यहां पे दिख रहा होगा कि दिस ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग हेडर इज़ चंग्ड।
अब चंग्ड की साइज है एट। सो इट्स एट। अब
एट क्या है? एट। चलिए देख लेते हैं
हेक्साडेेसिमल टू उसमें कन्वर्ट करके एट
इज़ कनवर्टेड टू द एक्चुअल वैल्यू एट तो ये
एट ही है जो वैल्यू है। तो यानी कि एट
बाइट की साइज का यहां पे हम दिखा रहे हैं।
तो स्मगल्ड कितने बाइट के साइज का है? 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 तो वैलिड है। ठीक है? परफेक्ट
फाइन। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। द फ्रंट एंड
सर्वर प्रोसेस द ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग हेडर
एंड सो इट ट्रीट्स द मैसेज बॉडी एज़ यूज़िंग
चंक्ड इनकोडिंग। चंक्ड इनकोडिंग इट
प्रोसेससेस द फर्स्ट चंक। यह फर्स्ट चंक
को प्रोसेस करेगा।
व्हिच इज़ स्टेटेड टू बी 8 बाइट लॉन्ग अप
टू द स्टार्ट ऑफ द फॉलोइंग ऑफ द लाइन
स्मग्ड।
ठीक है?
इट प्रोसेस द सेकंड चंक वि इज स्टेटेड टू
बी जीरो लेंथ एंड सो इट ट्रीटेड एस
टर्मिनेटिंग द रिक्वेस्ट। द रिक्वेस्ट इज़
फॉरवर्डेड टू द बैक एंड सर्वर। तो ये बैक
एंड के पास यहां तक स्मगल्ड तक जो है चली
जाएगी क्योंकि एट लेंथ है आपकी 8 बाइट की।
तो स्मगल्ड उसको मिल गया 8 बाइट का। अब ये
भेज देगा क्योंकि उसके बाद ज़ीरो है तो ये
टर्मिनेट कर देगा। और इतनी जो चीजें हैं
वो कहां भेज रहा है? वो भेज रहा है हमारे
सर्वर को।
हमारे सर्वर को tcl वाला बिलिटी तो चली गई
यह सर्वर सर्वर के पास यह पूरी की पूरी
डाटा। अब हम आते हैं नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे
स्टेप नंबर टू द बैक एंड सर्वर प्रोसेससेस
द कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर। अब बैक एंड सर्वर को
क्यों कंटेंट लेंथ देखना है? क्योंकि tcl
है। एंड डिटरमाइंस दैट द रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी
इज़ 3 बाइट लॉन्ग। अब बैक एंड सर्वर को
क्या दिख रहा है कि यह कंटेंट लेंथ थ्री
है। 3 बाइट्स का है। बस हो गया।
अप टू द स्टार्ट ऑफ द लाइन फॉलोइंग एट।
अब इसको तो थ्री ही दिख रहा है ना। द
फॉलोइंग बाइट्स स्टार्टिंग विद स्मगल्ड आर
लेफ्ट अनप्रसेस्ड एंड द बैक एंड सर्वर विल
ट्रीट दीज़ एज़ बीइंग एज़ द स्टार्ट ऑफ़ द
नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट इन द सीक्वेंस। यानी कि
अब बैक एंड कैसे प्रोसेस करेगी इसको? कि
भैया सर्वर के पास एक पूरा का पूरा
स्मगल्ड वर्ड स्मगल्ड जो है ना डेटा वो आ
चुका है। लेकिन सर्वर कंटेंट लेंथ में
थ्री देख रहा है। एक इंडिपेंडेंटली थ्री
देख रहा है। तो अब वो थ्री ही सिर्फ
प्रोसेस करेगा। इसके ये जो सब स्मगल्ड का
फर्स्ट थ्री बाइट है एसएमय इसी को प्रोसेस
करेगा। और बाकी जीजी एलईडी को छोड़ देगा
कि जाओ भाई हमें तुमसे कोई मतलब नहीं है।
हमें तो हुआ है प्यार एसएमय से। आपका हम
क्या करें? आपको हम छोड़ देते हैं। हमारे
बफर में जाकर पड़ जाओ। भले हम उसे हम
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग के शिकार हो जाएंगे
लेकिन बफर में पड़ जाओ। तो यहां पे सर्वर
ने क्या किया? एसएमय को ओनली पढ़ा एंड देन
इट स्टॉप्स रीडिंग द बॉडी। और उसके बाद ये
रुक गया क्योंकि इसको काम करना है कंटेंट
लेथ के अकॉर्डिंग। क्योंकि यहां पे टीसीएल
वनेबिलिटीज़ की बात हो रही है। अगर ये
वनेबिलिटीज़ है तो याद रखिएगा ये सारे
सिनेरियो तब होंगे जब ये वनेबिलिटीज़
एक्चुअल है।
तो इसने एसएमयू पढ़ लिया। अब क्या होगा
स्टेप थ्री में? नाउ बैकेंट्स हैज़ अनरीड
बाइट्स। बैकेंट के पास एक जीजी एलईडी और
ज़ीरो है। याद होगा आपको? ज़ीरो भी आई थी।
राइट? ज़ीरो भी तो आएगी ना भाई। ज़ीरो भी तो
ज़ीरो को कैसे छोड़ दोगे? ज़ीरो भी आएगी। द
नेक्स्ट रियल रिक्वेस्ट सेंट बाय द
विक्टिम विल अराइव लाइक। अब कोई एक और
रिक्वेस्ट जब नया एक रियल रिक्वेस्ट आएगा,
तो कुछ इस तरीके से आ सकता है। गेट
विक्टिम होस्ट वनरेबल वेबसाइट.com यह एक
एक जनरल रिक्वेस्ट आ गई मान लो। अब बैक
एंड कैसे इसको लेगा? जीजी एलईडी जीरो गेट
अपेंड कर देगा। अब यह एक तो पहले जी पोस्ट
सुना था। अब ये जीजी एलईडी ज़ीरो गेट कौन
सा मेथड है भाई? बैक एंड गेट कंफ्यूज्ड
स्लैश विक्टिम होस्ट वाले ने इट
इंटरप्रेट्स गेट विक्टिम एज़ द स्मगल
रिक्वेस्ट। अब ये गेट विक्टिम जो है यही
एक स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट के तौर पे एक पूरा
अपेंडेड स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट के तौर पे जाना
जाएगा।
दैट्स इट। जैसे कि पीछे में हमने इस केस
में यहां पे
इस केस में हमने देखा था कि ये पूरा का
पूरा एक स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट कहलाएगा। जी
पोस्ट गेट एचटीटीp ये उसी तरीके से यहां
पे भी आपका जो ये पूरा का पूरा रिक्वेस्ट
ये जो है बैक एंड जो है वो इसको एक स्मगल
रिक्वेस्ट समझेंगे। एंड दिस इज़ t डॉट सीएल
वोलेबिलिटी।
तो clt
में फ्रंट एंड कंटेंट लेंथ को
प्रायोरिटाइज करके बैक एंड ट्रांसपेरेंट
कोडिंग को करता है। T.Cl में जो फ्रंट एंड
है वह ट्रांसफरेंट कोडिंग को करेगा और बैक
एंड आपका कंटेंट लेंथ को प्रायोरिटाइज़
करेगा। उसी के अकॉर्डिंग काम करेगा। और
हमको डिसिंक्रोनाइजेशन करना है। डिसिंक
करना है। एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
वलेबिलिटीज़ को लानी है। तो हमको एक ही
रिक्वेस्ट में दोनों को ही यूज़ करना
पड़ेगा। दोनों हेडर को ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
भी और आपका कंटेंट लेंथ भी। क्योंकि
यूज़ुअली नहीं करना चाहिए। बट दोनों को
करना पड़ेगा। और दोनों के बीच में
डिफरेंसेस लाने पड़ेंगे। दोनों के बीच में
टकरार कराना पड़ेगा।
एक को दूसरे के अगेंस्ट ले जाना पड़ेगा।
या तो एक को दूसरे के अंदर हाइड करके ले
जाना पड़ेगा।
कि फ्रंट एंड अगर इस चीज पे एग्री कर रहा
है तो बैक एंड ना करें। बैक एंड अगर एग्री
कर रहा है तो फ्रंट एंड ना करें। फिर
दोनों में टकरार होगी और एसटीडी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग का उजागर होगा और आप अपने डाटा
को स्मगल करके सर्वर तक पहुंचाएंगे जो कि
एक मलिशियस रिक्वेस्ट हो सकती है। एक
मलशियस डाटा हो सकती है जो कि सर्वर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकती है। अकाउंट को
हाईजैक कर सकती है। अलग-अलग तरह के दूसरे
वनेबिलिटीज को अनकवर कर सकती है। अब इसको
हम एक
इमेज के थ्रू समझते हैं। टी सेल
वलेबिलिटीज। आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कि
एक अटैकर है। कंटेंट लेंथ थ्री है यहां
पे।
सॉरी एंड ट्रांसपेरेंट कोडिंग चंक्ड है एट
तो मैंने बताया था एट के बाद r n होता है।
फिर उसी तरीके से g पोस्ट के बाद r n 0 के
बाद स्लश r n देन लास्ट में rn कुछ नहीं
है तो इस तरीके से तो अब इसने क्या किया
क्योंकि ये tcl है तो ट्रांसफर कोडिंग
यूज़ हो रही है तो ट्रांसफर कोडिंग का 8
बाइट है तो इसने 8 बाइट को भेजा कैसे भेजा
तो ये 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 टोटल आठ हो गए
आठ बाइट को उसने भेज दिया सिंपल
यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे जो
बाइट्स हैं वो आप देख लीजिएगा। सॉरी
ये पूरे 8 बाइट मान लो यहां पे अब ये
डिनोशन का उतना ध्यान मत देना। इसमें एक
दो चीजें कम भी हो सकती हैं। तो उस ये एi
जनरेटेड है तो इस पे ज्यादा सीरियस नहीं
होना है। लेकिन 8 बाइट की डेटा जा रही है
ये। तो ये 1 2 3 जो ये आपका 8 बाइट का जो
भी डेट आपकी जा रही है वो आपकी यहां से जा
रही है। अब ये 8 ए 8 rn कैसे हो गया ये?
क्योंकि एट के बाद आपका स्लश R n जो है
आपका वो है। उसके बाद जो आपका न्यू लाइन
का RN है जो आपका और उसके बाद एक न्यू
लाइन का RN है। क्योंकि यहां पे जो हमारी
रिक्वेस्ट आई थी जो हमने भेजा था यहां पे
आप देखोगे यहां पे कि यहां पे ये एट है इस
तरीके से।
ठीक है?
एंड यहां पर आपका स्मगल्ड है जो डाटा है
एंड देन यहां पे जीरो है इस तरीके से तो
स्मगल्ड को हमने इसको तो भेज दिया था भैया
क्योंकि इसने ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को चूज़ किया
था चंक्ड को तो 8 बाइट को भेजना था तो
उसने भेज दिया था अब उसी तरीके से यहां पे
सर्वर के साइड से ये किस तरीके से आपका
अकाउंट होता है अटै हैकर किस तरीके से काम
करता है कि यूजज़ द फ्रंट एंड यूज़ ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग फॉरवर्ड्स एंटायर चंक्ड रिक्वेस्ट
अब जो भी चंग्ड रिक्वेस्ट है पूरा का पूरा
चंक्ड रिक्वेस्ट जो है उसको भेज देगी। अब
यहां पे मैंने एक दूसरा एग्जांपल लिया है।
यहां पे ये एक एग्जांपल दिस इज़ एन डिफरेंट
एग्जांपल एंड यहां पे एक डिफरेंट एग्जांपल
है। ठीक है? तो ये आपको अलग-अलग ये चीजें
मिल रही हैं। तो अब यहां पे ये डेटा है
मान लो तो इस तरीके से इसने पूरा चंक डेटा
पूरा का पूरा भेज दिया 8 बाइट का भेज
दिया। अब रिमेनिंग डेटा जो है प्रोसेससेस
8 आर एन जो भी है प्रोसेससेस उसमें आठ 8
बाइट का और रिमेनिंग डेटा को छोड़ दिया जी
पोस्ट वाली। तो जी पोस्ट वाली जो डाटा है
वो बफर में आ गई। तो फ्रंट एंड फॉरवर्ड्स
द होल रिक्वेस्ट बैक एंड प्रोसेस ओनली
स्मॉल पार्ट बेस्ड ऑन द कंटेंट लेंथ।
क्योंकि कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे है तीन। तो
बैक एंड जो है वो सिर्फ उसी तीन को लीविंग
द रेस्ट एज अ स्मगल्ड प्रीफिक्स। बाकी को
स्मगल प्रीफिक्स के तौर पे छोड़ देगी। एंड
बाकी तीन को ये प्रोसेस कर देगी।
स्टार्टिंग के जो तीन है तीन बस और कुछ भी
नहीं।
8 RN
बस 8 RN तो तीन यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
कंटेंट लेंथ तीन प्रोसेस 8 RN और रिमेनिंग
आपका जी पोस्ट वाला ये पूरा का पूरा हो
गया
बस और यहां पे क्योंकि ये ट्रांसपेरेंट
कोडिंग यूज़ हो रहा है तो इसने क्या किया
पूरा का पूरा चंक रिक्वेस्ट भेज दिया आगे
जो भी इसका जो भी रिक्वेस्ट है क्योंकि आठ
बाइट की जो भी रिक्वेस्ट होंगी पूरी वो
पूरी भेज दी अब इसने तो तीन ही कंटेन लेंथ
के अकॉर्डिंग काम करना है तो इसने तीन जो
8 r n 1 2 3 इस तीन को ही पढ़ा और बाकी जो
जी पोस्ट rn 0 आर एन सब है इन सबको सॉकेट
बफर में डाल दिया। अब जो नई रिक्वेस्ट
आएगी उसके अकॉर्डिंग फिर अब उसको स्मगल कर
देगा ये उसको टाई अप कर देगा। अब आती है
tt वालेबिलिटी। ये दोनों देख लिया आपने।
अब tt वालेबिलिटी क्या होती है? उसको भी
समझिए।
इसको समझते हैं।
tt में द फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्व्स
बोथ सर्वर्स बोथ सपोर्ट द ट्रांसफर इन
कोडिंग हेडर बट वन ऑफ़ द सर्वर्स कैन बी
इंड्यूस्ड नॉट टू प्रोसेस इट बाय ऑफ ऑफ
फस्टेटिंग द हेडर इन सम वे एक वाले से हम
छुपा लेंगे
एक जो है उससे हम हाइड कर लेंगे
तो ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को हाइड करने के
बहुत अलग-अलग अलग तरीके होते हैं। जैसे आप
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग के बाद चंग्ड ना लिख के
इसको एक्स चंग्ड लिख दें। ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग के बाद स्पेस देके चंग्ड लिख
दें। ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग के बाद टैब देके
चंग्ड लिख दें। ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंग्ड
एंड ट्रांसफर कोडिंग एक्स ऐसे लिख दें।
[हंसी]
स्पेस के बाद ट्रांसफर कोडिंग एंड देन
चंग्ड लिखें।
देन एक्स कॉलन एक्स न्यू लाइन ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग चंग्ड लिखें या ट्रांसफर कोडिंग
ऐसे लिख के नीचे न्यू लाइन पे कॉलन चंग्ड
लिखें ऐसे करके आप जो है एक चंग्ड को
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग चक्ड को हाइड कर सकते हो
अगर वनेरेबल होगी सर्वर तो ये हाइड हो
जाएगी इसको कंसीडर नहीं करेगा कोई एक
सर्वर या तो फ्रंट एंड या तो बैक एंड अब
इसमें क्या होता है टू अनकवर अ टीईटी
वनेबिलिटी इट इज़ नेसेसरी टू फाइंड सम
वेरिएशन ऑफ़ द ट्रांसफर कोडिंग हेडर सच दैट
ओनली वन ऑफ़ द फ्रंट एंड और बैक एंड सर्वर
प्रोसेस इट। मतलब कोई एक ही प्रोसेस करना
चाहिए ट्रांसफर एंड कोडिंग को। एंड द अदर
इग्नोरर्स इट। दूसरा इग्नोर कर दे। यह
होना चाहिए। इस ये नहीं होगा तो दिक्कत
होगी। डिपेंडिंग ऑन वेदर इट इज़ द फ्रंट
एंड और द बैक एंड सर्वर दैट कैन बी
इंड्यूस्ड नॉट टू प्रोसेस द ऑफ़ फस्टेटेड
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर। द रिमेनिंग ऑफ़ द
अटैक विल टेक सेम ऐज़ दैट CL.t और tcl अब
ये रिमेनिंग सेम हो जाएगा। अब खुद सोचो
सेम कैसे हो जाएगा? कि अगर मान लो कि
जो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर है वो ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को प्रायरिटाइज कर देती है और
बैक एंड सर्वर से हम हाइड कर देते हैं तो
क्या कौन सा अटैक हो जाएगा मुझे बता
दीजिए। अगर इस केस में मान लो टीईटी में
हम फ्रंट एंड फ्रंट एंड को प्रायोरिटाइज
करने देते हैं ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को और बैक
एंड से हाइड कर देते हैं। तो कौन सा
वनेबिलिटी फिर हमारा रिपीट होगा? बताइए
कौन सी वनेबिलिटी रिपोर्ट होगी हमारी?
कौन सी वबिलिटी को हम रिपीट करेंगे? इफ
प्रायरिटाइज
फ्रंट एंड को कर फ्रंट एंड कर दे ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को। हां अगर प्रायोरिटाइज जो
पहले होती है वही डॉट अदर तो प्रायरिटाइज
अगर ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को किया जा रहा है
यहां पे। ठीक है? अगर ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
को हम प्रायोरिटाइज़ कर रहे हैं फ्रंट एंड
के लिए तो ये ई ड.cl वाली वनेबिलिटी के
ऊपर बाकी सारा आपका होगा। जैसे पहले हमने
किया tcl और अगर हम फ्रंट एंड से हाइड कर
रहे हैं ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को और बैक एंड को
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को प्रायोरिटाइज करने दे
रहे हैं इसका मतलब है फिर clt वाली आ
जाएगी clt
तो ये है पूरा प्रोसेस तो अब ये देखिए
क्या होगा ये फ्रंट एंड है ये बैक एंड है
अब एक्सेप्ट्स एक्स चंग्ड एच चंग्ड अब
यहां पे हमने क्या
कि फ्रंट एंड को एक लेनियंट लीनिएंट
पार्सलर बनाया। मतलब यह बहुत ही थकेला
टाइप पार्सलर है कि अरे भाई ठीक है यार
जैसे तुम मुझे बोलोगे मैं कर दूंगा। और
बैक एंड को स्ट्रिक्ट वाला बनाया कि नहीं
ऐसे कैसे यार एक्सचंग का मतलब एक्सचंग
होता है। चंग्ड थोड़ी ना होता है। मतलब
यहां पे बैक एंड को हमने बहुत स्ट्रिक्ट
बनाया कि अगर एक्सचंग हम उसको देंगे तो वो
बोलेगा ना आई विल नॉट इशू नॉट यूज़ इट। आई
विल नॉट अलाउ इट। बट हम फ्रंट एंड को बहुत
लीनिएंट बना रहे हैं। एंड फ्रंट एंड को
बोलेंगे तो ये क्या करेगा? एक्स चंक्ड को
चक्ड ही समझ लेगा। वो समझेगा अच्छा अच्छा
एक्स चक्क चंक्ड ही तो है। यूसेस ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग। अब यहां पे ये क्या करेगा कि ये
देखो पोस्ट http 111 1.1 RN होस्ट
एग्जांपल RN कंटेंट लेंथ 10 RN ट्रांसफर
इन कोडिंग एक्स चंक्ल RN
अब यहां पे इसको ये क्या करेगा? चंक्ड मान
लेगा फ्रंट एंड
और बैक एंड क्या करेगा? डज़ नॉट रिकॉग्नाइज़
एक्सचेंट। बैक एंड उसको रिकॉग्नाइज़ नहीं
करेगा। इग्नोर ट्रांसफर कोडिंग फॉल्स बैक
टू कंटेंट लेंथ। बैक एंड क्या करेगा कि
एक्सचेंट को रिकॉग्नाइज़ नहीं करेगा। वो
इसको इग्नोर मार देगा ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को।
और यहां पे वो कंटेंट लेंथ को यूज़ करने
लगेगा। तो यहां पे क्या हुआ कि फ्रंट एंड
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को यूज़ कर रहा है। बैक
एंड कंटेंट लेंथ को यूज़ कर रहा है। तो
यहां पे T.Cl वालेबिलिटी इसज़ को हम देख
सकते हैं। यही सेम अगर रिवर्स कर देंगे तो
cl.t वाली वालेबिलिटी आ जाएगी।
दैट्स द थिंग। तो ऑफ फस्टेटेड हेडर्स कैन
लीड टू वन वन सर्वर ऑनरिंग टी ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग व्हाइल द अदर इग्नोर्स इट क्रिएट्स
अ डिसिंक कंडीशन। अगर एक एग्री एक जो है
वो अगर उसको एक्सेप्ट करता है दूसरा
रिजेक्ट कर देता है तो यहां पे डिसिंक हो
जाती है। वहां पे डिसिंक्रोनाइजेशन हो
जाती है। एंड दैट्स द मेन बिल्डिंग ब्लॉक
ऑफ दिस एसटीडीपीस स्मगलिंग अटैक। यही मेन
कांसेप्ट है आपका। दैट्स द थिंग। दिस इज़ द
मेन कांसेप्ट। समझ में आया कि उड़ गया? अरे
बताओ भाई।
देखो कितने कम लोग हुए हैं। बाकी वबिलिटीज
में इतने कम नहीं होते हैं। रहते हैं काफी
लोग। इस वबिलिटी में काफी लोग कम हो गए
हैं। इसका रीज़न मुझे अच्छे से पता है कि
दे कैन नॉट प्रोसेस इट। उनको समझ नहीं आया
होगा बहुत सारी चीजें। बट कोई बात नहीं
मल्टीपल टाइम देख के प्रैक्टिस करें।
2 आवर्स कंप्लीटेड पता भी नहीं चला। क्या
बात है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। आप काफी
इंटरेस्ट लेके देख रहे हैं। तभी आपको नहीं
पता चला। अदरवाइज कई लोग तो भाग गए।
कोई तरीका है क्या सर? कि यह स्मगल
रिक्वेस्ट अटैकर के हैं। अटैकर के ही पास
आए हैं। बार किसी अनदर यूजर के पास जाए।
समझा नहीं मैं इस क्या आप बोल रहे हो? शिव
शिवम थोड़ा आप क्लियर अगर बताओ लिखोगे तो
मैं समझ जाऊंगा।
ये जो आप भेज रहे हो ना ये दूसरे यूज़र्स
को भी
जो है ना डिसरप्ट कर सकते हैं। बिल्कुल कर
सकते हैं। पॉसिबिलिटी है बट वेरी लेस बहुत
लेस पॉसिबिलिटी है।
थोड़ा लेस पॉसिबिलिटी है। थोड़ा सा हार्ड
है। है ना?
ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं। अब यहां पर देखो इस
पर्टिकुलर एचटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग का
अटैक इंपैक्ट क्या होता है? पहला अटैक
इंपैक्ट होता है डेटा थफ्ट वाया रिक्वेस्ट
हाईजैकिंग। पहला अटैक का जो इंपैक्ट होता
है वो डेटा थफ्ट होता है आपका इस एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग का।
करेक्ट। क्योंकि इस वेलेबिलिटी में
थ्योरेटिकल पार्ट बहुत ज्यादा है। इसलिए
इसे बाकी के लोग लाइव स्ट्रीम छोड़ के
चलेगा। हां, बिलकुल सही बोला विनय।
यह बिल्कुल सच्चाई है कि अ सच्चाई और बहुत
बहुत सैडनेस वाली बात है। मैं पता नहीं
कितने टाइम से ये चीज बोलता आ रहा हूं। बट
समझते नहीं है लोग। बिगिनर्स नहीं समझते
स्पेशली जो थोड़े समझदार हो चुके हैं वह
तो समझ जाते हैं कि
आप
बिना कांसेप्ट के ना बिना
थ्योरी के अगर आप कुछ करते हैं प्रैक्टिकल
कर और लेते हैं तो उसका मैं कोई वैल्यू
नहीं मैं नहीं मानता कि उसकी कोई वैल्यू
है। मैं नहीं मानता कि वो चीज कुछ है। वो
तो कोई भी कर लेगा यार प्रैक्टिकल बच्चा
भी कर लेगा। पीछे का कांसेप्ट पीछे की
टेक्नोलॉजी पीछे की
वो एक वे तरीका वो क्या है वो आपको समझना
जरूरी है ना यार वो नहीं समझोगे तो कैसे
काम चलेगा खुद तो सोचो दैट्स द मेन थिंग
प्रैक्टिकल से मतलब होता है ओनली
करेक्ट अब यहां पे आते हैं। प्रैक्टिकल भी
आएगा। लेकिन आप सोचिए ना आप खुद सोचो। खुद
सोचो इसका प्रैक्टिकल भी आएगा। मैं
प्रैक्टिकल भी लेकर आऊंगा। राइट?
हां। प्रैक्टिकल भी मैं लेकर आऊंगा। लेकिन
ये किस उनको समझ में आएगा जो लोग छोड़ के
चले गए अभी लाइफ? बिल्कुल नहीं आएगा। क्या
है? वो देख के खुश हो जाएंगे थोड़ा। अरे
अटैक हो गया, हाईजैक हो गई। अरे मजा आ गया
यार। बट उनको समझ में कभी नहीं आएगा।
क्योंकि उन्होंने ये चीज करा ही नहीं ना।
कांसेप्ट समझा ही नहीं। तो कहां से समझ
में आएगा? सिंपल सा फंडा है ना?
ठीक है। चलिए अटैक इंपैक्ट देखते हैं। अब
इस अटैक का क्या-क्या इंपैक्ट हो सकता है?
हालांकि बहुत इंपैक्ट है। कुछ मेजर कॉमन
इंपैक्ट देखते हैं। डाटा थफ्ट वाया
रिक्वेस्ट हाईजेकिंग। अब ये लेजिटमेट यूजर
है। ठीक है? अब क्या करेगा? यह एक
रिक्वेस्ट भेजेगा गेट account http
example.com इसमें एक कुकी का वैल्यू जा
रहा है। सीक्रेट कुकी सेशन कुकी की वैल्यू
जा रही है। अब ये सॉकेट बफर बना हुआ है।
वही जो मैंने अभी पूरा कांसेप्ट बताया
उससे एक सॉकेट बफर बनी है। एचटीडीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग से उसमें क्या है?
अटैकर का सर्वर है। होस्ट क्या है? अटैकर
का सर्वर है। कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे दिया
हुआ है। कि इतने कंटेंट लेंथ तक यहां पे
भेजिए भाई। अब बैक एंड जो है वो क्या
करेगा? हाईजेक्ट रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी जो है
उसके उसको कहां पहुंचाएगा? अटैकर के
सर्वर। अटैकर के सर्वर के पास क्या
पहुंचेगी? तो गेट अकाउंट होस्ट क्या है?
एग्जांपल.com यानी इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर का
अकाउंट का एक्सेस इस पर्टिकुलर अटैकर के
पास चला जाएगा। उसके साथ वो चला जाएगा।
उसमें ये कुकी जो है सीक्रेट कुकी वैल्यू
है वो चली जाएगी। कुकी वैल्यू चली जाएगी।
वो अकाउंट हाईजैक हो जाएगी। सिंपल। सो, द
विक्टिम्स रिक्वेस्ट इंक्लूडिंग कुकीज़ इज़
अपेंडेड टू अ स्मगल्ड पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट
बॉडी एंड सेंट टू अटैकर सर्वर्स। यह डाटा
थफ्ट पॉसिबिलिटी है बाय दिस पर्टिकुलर
थिंग।
नेक्स्ट इज़ इंपैक्ट क्या है? कैश
पोइजनिंग। इससे कैश पोइजनिंग भी होती है।
दिस आल्सो कैन लीड टू कैश पोइजनिंग।
कैश पोइजनिंग कैसे होती है? कि एक अटैकर
है। ये लेजिट मेट यूजर है। अब क्या होती
है? फ्रंट एंड सर्वर है। उसका अपना एक कैश
स्टोरेज होता है। जैसे सर्वर्स के कैश
मेमोरी होते हैं। वैसे। अब इस कैश मेमोरी
में क्या हुआ क्या है कि लेजिटमेट यूजर ने
एक नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट करा गेट स्टैटिक
स्क्रिप्ट जेएस ठीक है एंड अटैकर ने एक
मलशियस स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट भेजा है इसी फ्रंट
एंड को और मलेशियस जो रिक्वेस्ट भेजा है
उस मलेशियस रिक्वेस्ट की वजह से कैश
स्टोरेज में एक मलशियस कंटेंट आके कैश्ड
हो गई है जो कि है स्टैटिक स्क्रिप्ट जेस
और इसी मलेशियस कंटेंट को इस फ्रंट एंड
सर्वर ने क्या किया कैश स्टोरेज से उठा के
यूजर को कैश मलिशियस रिस्पांस पहुंचा
दिया। यूजर को कैश मलिशियस रिस्पांस
पहुंचा दिया। अब ये क्या करेगा? मलिशियस
रिस्पांस क्या है? इसका एक्सेस स्क्रिप्ट
हो सकती है। दिस माइट बी एन एक्सेस
स्क्रिप्ट।
तो अगर यह एक्सेस स्क्रिप्ट मलेशियस यहां
पर कैश में है और यह यूजर को डिलीवर हो
रही है तो यूजर के पास एक्सेस जो टारगेट
है वहां एक्सेस पॉप अप हो जाएगा। एक्सेस
ट्रिगर हो जाएगा। ये सोच रहे हो समझ रहे
हो कितनी खतरनाक बात है। ये एक तरह का किस
तरह का एक्सेस है? बताइए। ये जब आप इसको
विजुअलाइज करेंगे कि एक अटैकर ने कैश
मेमोरी में एक एक्सेस स्क्रिप्ट रखी है जो
कि स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट के थ्रू एक दूसरे यूजर
के पास एग्जीक्यूट हो के एक्सेस दे दे रहा
है। ये किस तरह का एक्सेस के कैटेगरी में
फॉल करेगा बताइए मुझे।
लेट मी नो व्हिच टाइप ऑफ़ एक्सेस इट कैन बी
देखते हैं।
बिल्कुल सही।
एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट। सो दिस विल बी अ काइंड
ऑफ़ ब्लाइंड एक्सेसिस।
करेक्ट बिल्कुल। ये एक ब्लाइंड एक्सेस के
कैटेगरी में आ जाएगा आपका। एंड
सोचो एक एसटीp रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग से आपने
एक ब्लाइंड एक्सेसिस परफॉर्म कर दिया। एंड
उससे पता नहीं अकाउंट टेक ओवर कर लें आप।
राइट? सो ये भी इंपैक्ट होता है आपके
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग का जहां पे
आपका कैश पोइजनिंग होता है। अब ये तो आपका
पूरा कांसेप्ट मैंने आपको ये चीज समझाई।
ये पूरी कांसेप्ट मैंने आपको समझाई। बट इस
कांसेप्ट के अलावा अभी चीजें बची हैं। वो
क्या है कि मैं आपको
हाउ
डू एचटीटीपी? मेन जो है यहां पे अब आते
हैं
हाउ डू एचटीडीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
अराइज़?
ठीक है? कैसे यह अराइज़ करते हैं? किस
तरीके से यह
बढ़ते हैं? एंड सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज हाउ टू
आइडेंटिफाई एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
वलेबिलिटी। इनको हम आइडेंटिफाई कैसे
करेंगे? सबसे बड़ी चीज ये है। अभी तक तो
आपने कांसेप्ट समझा।
थैंक्स ब्रदर विनोद ठाकुर। थैंक यू विनोद।
अभी तक तो आपने ये कांसेप्ट समझा। अब यहां
पे दो चीजें आती हैं। इसकी प्रैक्टिस,
प्रैक्टिकल एंड ये कैसे आइडेंटिफाई करें?
आप किसी भी एक रिक्वेस्ट में एक किसी भी
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
पे पाथ को किस तरीके से इंटरसेप्ट करके
एंड कैसे आप पता लगाएंगे कि ये एक्चुअली
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग वालेबिलिटी
इसमें एग्जिस्ट करती है कि नहीं है। तो वो
तरीका वो फाइंड करने का अप्रोच वो सारी
चीजें ये हम नेक्स्ट पार्ट में देखेंगे।
एंड प्रैक्टिकल जो है वो भी हम नेक्स्ट
पार्ट में देखेंगे। इसको हम प्रैक्टिकली
देखेंगे। लैब्स के थ्रू, रियल वेबसाइट पे
सब जगह ट्राई करेंगे, देखेंगे एंड उसको
परफॉर्म करेंगे। बट याद रखिएगा बिना इस
थ्यरी के, बिना इस कांसेप्ट के यू आर नॉट
गोइंग टू अंडरस्टैंड द प्रैक्टिकल्स
आल्सो। क्योंकि प्रैक्टिकल्स में और भी
थोड़ी कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी आएगी एंड कैसे
आइडेंटिफाई करना है इसमें भी थोड़ी सी
कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी आएगी। क्योंकि कांसेप्ट
क्लियर रहेगा तो कैसे आइडेंटिफाई करना है
वो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। अब मेरी आप सब
से एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप जब ये सेशन खत्म
हो जाए तो नेक्स्ट जो भी आपकी सेशन आएंगी
इसकी प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट एंड इसका कैसे
आइडेंटिफाई करना है उसके पहले इस सेशन को
एक बार वापस रिवाइज कीजिएगा एंड Lindin पे
जाके आपने आज के सेशन में क्या सीखा है इस
इस पर्टिकुलर अ चीज से इस पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक
से वो Lindin पे जाके पोस्ट कीजिएगा एंड
हमें टैग कीजिएगा डिफ्रॉनिश को टैग
कीजिएगा कि आपने आज के सेशन से क्या-क्या
मेन पॉइंट्स निकाले हैं क्या-क्या मेन
पॉइंट्स सीखे पॉइंट वाइज आप लिख दीजिएगा
एंड हमें हमें पता चलेगा एंड कि आप
एक्चुअली एक्टिव है और हमें टैग कर
दीजिएगा। वी विल गेट टू नो। बस इतना ही
आपको करना है। दैट्स इट। दैट्स इट फॉर
टुडे। दैट्स इट फॉर दिस सेशन एंड आई रियली
रियली एंजॉयड
टीचिंग यू दिस टॉपिक। बिकॉज़ ये टॉपिक अपने
आप में एक एक्सटेंसिव रिसर्च टॉपिक है।
मैंने इस पे भी काफी रिसर्च किए हैं। तब
जाके आपके सामने ये टॉपिक लेकर आया हूं।
तो उसकी थोड़ी सी वो करो एंड अपने दोस्तों
के बीच इसको शेयर करना आप जब स्ट्रीम खत्म
हो जाए। जितने भी आपके ग्रुप्स हैं,
पब्लिक ग्रुप है, प्राइवेट ग्रुप्स हैं,
Instagram, Facebook, Telegram, WhatsApp
हर जगह आप फॉरवर्ड कर सकते हैं। इसको शेयर
कर सकते हैं ताकि हमारे कंटेंट इस लेवल के
कंटेंट सब तक पहुंचे। एटलीस्ट जो नॉलेज है
उसको शेयर करना चाहिए। नॉलेज शुड बी ओपन
सोर्स एंड इट शुड बी शेयरर्ड। अपने तक
नहीं रखना चाहिए। कि जितना शेयर करोगे ना
उतनी नॉलेज आपकी गेन होती है। उतनी नॉलेज
आपकी बढ़ती है। तो डोंट हेजिटेट इन लेटिंग
अदर्स नो अबाउट दिस। अदर्स को भी पढ़ने का
मौका दो, सीखने का मौका दो। इससे आपकी खुद
की प्रगति होगी। इस बात की गारंटी मैं
देता हूं आपको। ऐसा ही होता है। शेयर इट।
इससे हमारी हेल्प होती है। हमारी हमारी
काफी उससे सपोर्ट होती है। जब आप शेयर
करते हैं हमारी वीडियोस को एंड हमारे पास
लोग आते हैं एंड हमारे इस कंटेंट को
यूटिलाइज करते हैं जो कि एक एक्चुअल
जेन्युइन कंटेंट होता है।
या या वेलकम विनय नेक्स्ट पार्ट बहुत जल्द
आएगी क्योंकि इसी का पार्ट है तो वो
वीडियो इतना डिले आपका नहीं होगा बहुत
जल्द बहुत कुछ दिनों के अंदर आपका नेक्स्ट
पार्ट आएगा जिसमें हम प्रैक्टिकल एंड कैसे
इसको आइडेंटिफाई करें सब कुछ करें तब तक
आप इसी को प्रोसेस कीजिए जरूरी नहीं है
आपको फर्दर आगे बहुत सारे प्रोसेस करने के
आप इसी को पहले प्रोसेस करो यही बहुत
ज्यादा है प्रोसेस करो नोट्स बनाओ बस
दैट्स इट दैट्स द मेन थिंग
सब
अ इट इज़ वेरी ट्रू दैट दिस टॉपिक इज़ अ बिट
हार्ड टू अंडरस्टैंड बट यू मेड इट चीजी
क्लियर। थैंक्स अ लॉट। थैंक थैंक्स आकाश।
अ
या विनय थैंक थैंक यू सो मच। वेलकम ब्रदर
वेलकम। थैंक्स आयुष। चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात
है। आप लोगों को अच्छा लगा। चलो काफी लोग
हैं जो काफी सिंसियरली देखते हैं। मुझे
उनसे काफी ज्यादा मतलब होता है। काफी
ज्यादा उम्मीदें होती हैं। आई होप कि आप
इसी तरीके से कंटिन्यू करेंगे। दैट्स इट।
हमें रिटर्न में मैंने पहले ही बोला कुछ
नहीं चाहिए। कुछ भी नहीं चाहिए। आप बस
शेयर करते रहिए। हमारी वीडियोस हर जगह
पहुंचे। उसी से मतलब है हमें। सब्सक्राइब
नहीं करते हो। अगर नहीं करा हो तो
सब्सक्राइब कीजिए चैनल को। बेल आइकॉन को
प्रेस कर दीजिए ताकि जो है हमें उस चीज का
आपको नोटिफिकेशन वगैरह मिलता रहे। दैट्स
इट। ठीक है? और हां वीपीएस चेक करना हो तो
इंटेक डीसी वाली वीपीएस चेक कर लीजिएगा जो
मैंने आपको बताया था। कूपन कोड
डिफ्रॉनिक्स 20 यूज़ कर लीजिएगा। फर्स्ट
मंथ पे 20% का आपको डिस्काउंट मिल जाएगा।
कोई भी वीपीएस प्लान आप इनका चूज़ करेंगे।
बस सिंपल आपको 20% का फ्लैट डिस्काउंट मिल
जाएगा फर्स्ट मंथ के लिए। एंड यू कैन
ट्राई इट्स अ ग्रेट वीपीएस। काफी अच्छा ये
प्रोवाइड करते हैं। बग बाउंट के लिए आप
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। मैं काफी पर्सनली इसको
काफी टाइम से यूज़ कर रहा हूं।
डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी आपको कोड और लिंक मिल
जाएगी। ठीक है? आप वहां से भी इसको चेक
आउट कर सकते हैं। दैट्स इट फॉर टुडे सेशन
गाइस। थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन
एंड लेट्स मीट इन द नेक्स्ट वन। ओके?
थैंक्स अ लॉट। गुड नाइट टू ऑल ऑफ यू। बाकी
कोई बात हो बग हंटिंग वाली ग्रुप ज्वाइन
कर लेना। हर वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में
बग हंटिंग वाली ग्रुप की लिंक मिलेगी।
WhatsApp ग्रुप। उसको ज्वाइन कर लेना और
वहां पे अपने जो भी सवाल है उसको भेज
दीजिएगा। थैंक्स अ लॉट। बाय-ब टेक केयर।
गुड नाइट टू एवरीबॉडी।
थैंक्स।
बाय गुड नाइट गुड नाइट सभी गुड नाइट बोल
दो लाइक ठोक दो और गुड नाइट बोल दो और चले
जाओ लाइक ठोको गुड नाइट बोलो और जाओ
ओके बाय
आ